nest js is a framework for building
scalable node.js web applications with
typescript in this course vlad will
teach you an sjs by teaching you how to
build a rest api
hello and welcome to this course my name
is vladimir i am a full stack software
developer in this course we are going to
build a crud rest api with nest gs our
goal is to build something as close as
possible to a production app we will
implement authentications end-to-end
tests and we will work with relational
databases as well as with a modern
development orm such as prisma my
teaching style is very hands-on i'm a
firm believer that you only learn by
doing all my code is very easy to follow
but if you are stuck you will find a
github repository with a completed
project in the description below
additionally feel free to leave
questions in the comment section or on
my channel code with flood i will try to
answer to them as soon as i can this
course requires a basic understanding of
javascript es6 and typescript but don't
worry if you don't have it as i will
explain everything in a step-by-step
fashion
so what is nest gs not to be confused
with next gs which is a front-end react
framework nest gs is a node.js backend
framework it fully embraces typescript
and it's also a very different problem
from let's say express.js it solves
architecture the weak point of
express.js see if you're using expressgs
it's very unopinionated it doesn't give
you a direction of how your project
should be structured or how you should
do things and while express.js can work
out very fine for small projects once
your project starts to grow and if you
are not an experienced developer that
knows how to structure it and scale it
properly it can quickly become a mess
but an sgs is not just another framework
in the sense that it does not try to
reinvent the wheel it actually uses
express gs under the hood so you can see
it as an abstraction of express gs and
in a nutshell it allows to create
testable scalable and easily
maintainable applications for an sgs
modularity is very important it uses
concept like dependency injection and it
is often branded as the angular for
backhand so now that you have an idea of
what nest gs is
why would you use it well structure
modularity
native typescript support a lot of
functionality out of the box easily
integrates with graphql microservices
rest api and has very good documentation
on security it also tremendously grows
in popularity which is a very important
factor to consider in fact right now
nest gs is the most popular back-end
framework below express on the same
level as co-igs and above adonis
loopback feather gs and even meteor plus
employers really love it because it
brings architecture structure and it's
easier to hire developers because they
don't need to learn a new custom
architecture every time they are on
board on a express.js project
so after that long explanation let's
jump into our project and code our an
sgs application and in this project we
are going to build a api application
programming interface this will be a
crud api
which is a very common terms for apis
and the resources that we are going to
either update read delete or create will
be bookmarks so without further ado
let's get started
before we start we need to have node.js
installed i'm using the version 16 but
any future version with a long term
support should work you also need to
have nest gs installed
so you need to install their cli
globally and sgs cli
then we can jump into our terminal and
create our new project with nest
new
and let's name it nest gs api tutorial
the cli will ask you to choose a package
manager i really like to go ahead with
yarn
perfect now our project is installed we
can
navigate into it i will open it with
code vs code but you can of course use
any editor of your choice and let me
make the code bigger this is vs code
visual studio code the theme i'm using
here is material theme and the icons you
see here is material icons you can
download them and install it here via
their extension menu so next gs has
created a
starter project for us it has a source
folder where our files are it has a test
folder where it gives the end-to-end
tests and it has some configuration
files here let's first clean it up we
don't need the
app controller spec and
we don't need the app.service
and nor do we need the app.controller
and since all those
files were imported into the app module
we need to go and delete them here
so for nest modules are very important
you see that this file the global file
is called app.module.ts
this is similar to something that we
have in react where we have a app.js or
app.ds file so this will be the main
module of the app that will import other
modules so i have talked about modules
but i haven't introduced what is a
module so
for any concept related to nest gs you
can just go into the nsgs documentation
and it's on the nsgs.com and you click
on documentation and you'll have this
page where you will have a lot of docs
on any uh concept that you want and for
instance here
module it's written that it's a class
annotated with the module decorator and
in fact we have a class called app
module that has been annotated with the
module decorator if it's not annotated
with the module decorator for net gs
it's not a module and if you don't know
what a decorator is it creates just a
function that
adds
some metadata to to the to the current
class or or function that it is kind of
decorating so it just adds more property
to to that class so if we go back to the
modules
documentation we see that
a module can import other modules and it
is the case for the application module
so the main module the root module it
can for instance import user module
orders module chat model any module that
you want
and every module can itself import also
controllers
and providers we are going to talk about
those a bit later but for now know that
a module can import other modules and
usually i like to organize my modules
into feature modules so if i have an
application where for instance we have
bookmarks well
what would be the parts of the
the application right you will have the
authentication
logic where a user can create its
profile login sign up so for me it will
be alt module then you will have maybe
user module that will handle the
logic related to the user we'll have
also the bookmarks module and maybe the
database module so you see you organize
your app into those features right and
you break it down into modules and the
result is that it makes your app
much more easier to handle and to reason
about let me show you a another project
i am working on just to illustrate the
structure so i have a source folder and
you see i have an odd module uh category
command post prisma which is a orm for
the database user and if i click here
you see that you have some data you have
the module as as as we expect and we
have some providers those we are going
to talk about it a bit later but this is
an example of a kind of production-ready
uh project so you guys can see the
organization and the code structure
in a nutshell of of nesgus projects okay
so we now know that modules organize
your app right and they are declared
with a class annotated by the creator
module so let's go ahead and declare
another class another module to break
down our application into those small
submodules so we know that we are
creating a bookmark application
what would there be in a bookmark
application well i have already touched
upon the authentication so in our crowd
api i want to be able to create users
and
to allow them to log in right so we will
have an authentication module let's go
ahead and create a odd module and
usually the convention is that you need
to put the modules you create in a
folder and the only time that you can
not respect this convention is when you
are using the main app module uh
component that will import all the other
kind of modules or components so let's
go ahead and create the folder here and
let's name it odd
and at first i'm going to show you how
to create it manually when you're using
a framework for the first time it's
better to actually write everything on
your own and not use any generators
because nest gs has a generator has a
cli command that allows you to kind of
automate that creation and we are going
to see that in a in a moment but
at first let's just write it by hand so
we get a bit of a muscle memory going on
so we create a folder called odd right
what do we know about modules we know
that it should be it should be a class
that should be annotated by a decorator
module so let's create a file and we
just respect that convention that if we
have a file we try to add the its kind
of function to its extension so this is
an extension right dot gs is an
extension dot ts is an extension dot
cpp for c plus plus would be an
extension as well so here it since it's
a module it will be the
odd.module.ts and we are using
typescript for all the projects so it's
ts
and
we need to create a class so it will be
odd module right
and we need to decorate it with a
decorator
called module and that decorator comes
from the nsgs common
module and we just need to open it
provide an object and that's it that's
the minimum
requirements to create a
a module so all we need to do is to save
and that's it we have created a module
and we have forgotten something
important we have forgotten to export
that class so if we don't
type export
this class will be available only inside
that module only inside that file we
need to export it to allow other files
of our application to use that so we go
back to app module
and
now we can just import odd module and we
can use the typescript intellisense to
help us to find our modules and files so
here it knows that the old module exists
inside out so all we need to do is to
click here if it doesn't appear you can
always do command dot or control dot and
it will propose you an option to import
it from the odd module
file and here it is to verify that our
logic works let's go ahead and launch
our next gs application
so
the bootstrap logic is inside man.ts it
looks a bit like what we could expect
from a express gs application right so
we have the app that is being
instantiated here and then we launch a
server on port 3000 i will use port 333
because usually the port 3000 is
reserved for react in my development
pipeline so i prefer to use
3333 i save it and now i open the
terminal in the
project let me clean that out and
all i need to do is i need to do yarn
start dev
and all those scripts are actually
defined here inside the package.json
we have start and we have start devs so
the reason why i'm using start dev and
not start is because start dev will
watch our files and recompile the code
when needed so if we do
yarn start dev it will launch next gs
and we don't have any errors which means
that it's very good everything has
compiled correctly net gs has
generated a dist file so a
kind of output compiled javascript file
from
typescript we don't need to really worry
about it it's just how nsgs works and
that's it we have our api working so
let's clean that up and um
and come back here so modules allow us
to break our app down into smaller
components that we can
easily
manage let's go ahead and create the
user module and the bookmark module in
this case i'm going to use the nest cli
to create those modules so you have an
idea about how it works
just open the terminal and we'll going
to open a new terminal session and we
execute nest
g for generate module and we name it
user and nest will generate the module
for us and automatically import it into
the app.module for us so we have a
folder user with a user.module class
here and we do the same thing with a
bookmark
right
and it also generates a bookmark module
for us and if we check our terminal
let's kill this one we see that the
application is still logging if i for
instance press ctrl save you see that it
is recompiled so everything is working
correctly
now let's add more logic to our
application so let's add the login logic
so when we build an sgs application we
usually separate our logic into
controllers and service we can refer to
the documentation and basically it says
that controllers are responsible for
handling incoming requests and returning
responses for the clients and providers
or services are responsible for
executing the business logic so we
separate our logic into controllers and
service or providers to be able to
to simplify what we do right so let's go
ahead and implement it
we go now into oauth module and we
create a service and a controller so
again the same can be done within sgs
cli and we're going to do it by hand the
first time so let's create a controller
odd.controller.ts
and
dot
odd.service.tn
if we go to out.controller we need to
create a class class odd controller
we need to annotate it with the
decorator controller
neshds knows that it's a controller
and we need to do the same for
earth.service
class
odd
service
for the service we need to annotate it
with the decorator injectable
and that just means that it's going to
be able to
use the dependency injection that nest
cs uses under the hood but more on that
a bit later
and we need to of course export those
otherwise we will not be able to import
those classes in our application
and since we have added it we need to
add that to the module as well
so controllers
hot
controller
and providers
hot.service
let's check our application if it's
running correctly okay no errors cool
running good so i've introduced the
dependency injection but i haven't
really said what it is you can of course
google it
online but let's go ahead and introduce
it with a concrete example to see how it
works so we have a odd service class and
we have a odd controller crisis right
um what is happening usually is that the
controller will need to call the servers
so the controller will receive a request
from the internet for instance a post
request asking to log in a user right
and then it's going to call a function
from the auth.service class
and return its result back to to the
client back to the browser but to do so
earth controller will have to
instantiate a a odd service class right
because in the end it's it's javascript
so if you want to create that instance
for instance it would be
a service it's equal
new or service right to avoid doing that
to avoid having to manage where it's
created and who manages it all we use
dependency injection that means that
instead of our controller to actually
have to declare it for instance to
actually have to do something
something like that
give me the
service here give me that
an instance of that class and i don't
care how to instantiate it just give me
an instance and this is how you do it in
sgs
private or service
odd
service
and that's it
nes gs will handle on itself how to
instantiate the odd service and how to
pass it to you in that old controller
file so you don't need to really worry
about and private here if you have never
seen that notation it just means
it just means that
and then have to do something like this
odd service it's equal odd service
instead of doing that
you just write private
and you scrap off this
that's a that's just a shorthand and if
we check our code we see that it is
being executed so everything is okay
everything is compiled and now if we
want like if we put a function into the
odd service called test this function is
not going to return anything
if we want we can call
this function directly like that
right
so that's dependency injection in a
nutshell if you wanna have more
information just google it there's a
plethora of
explanations online how it really works
this is how nsgs uses it and basically
it allows us to
not handle dependency management and it
it's just easier to work with when we
have dependency injection
so let's come back to the odd service
and create two functions because
our oauth module will manage two
functionality login and sign up so let's
go ahead and
create a function login and sign up
right
and that's all he's going to do for now
the odd service will store the business
logic right now there's none so let's
come back to the odd.controller and
create two endpoints an endpoint for
login and an endpoint for signup
so the way to do it again is using
decorators it just simplifies how you
write your logic so we expect a post
request on sign up and a post request on
login so we create
a function let's name it sign up
right and sign in
and and to make it a route we just need
to annotate it with the post the creator
that comes from nsgs common
and let's call it
sign up
and sign in
and since we are in the od controller
it's usually a good practice to put a
global prefix route called aut so when
we are going to call that route we need
to do a post request of to out sign up
right and if we call that route it's
going to be that
that request
let's just return a string for now
i am
sign up
and here i am
signed
in
let's verify that the product is
compiling all good and let's go ahead
and test our api with insomnia so
insomnia is a http client similar to
postman you can also use postman if you
have if you are used to it insomnia is
just a bit more minimalistic and easier
to use so let's go ahead and test our
endpoint and if you remember our old
controller was on the endpoint out sign
up
and
right
and we do the send request and we see
that we have response right i am sign up
and that is basically what we have
written here right and if we launch and
if we request sign in it's going to
print us the other response one
interesting thing though is that if we
look at the headers we see that it is
powered by express so as i said it in
the beginning an sgs uses express under
the hood you can replace it by another
framework called fastify but for most
use cases you will probably use express
and that's going to be just fine that
also means that everything that you know
about express you can access it so this
is a nice thing about nest gs if you
like express gs and you need more
structure in your app you can use net cs
and still have access to that express
ecosystem if you need one other thing
that is very interesting is that express
has sent us a content type of text html
right so this is a text so net gs will
automatically convert the data type
based on the return so here it's a
string if i send a object
for instance message hi
or hello
and we send it to sign up
we now have a object and the header is
application.json so that's a very handy
you don't need to worry about sending
the right data type and sgs will do it
for you let's go back to our app and
let's create more logic so as i said in
the beginning the controllers will
handle the requests so it will fetch the
body of the request if needed it might
check some headers or any work related
to the request regarding the business
logic the actual execution we offload
that to the service usually the pattern
is that we are going to create the same
function on the service side so let's go
ahead and do it
we have a function now sign up
and sign in
all right
and instead of returning something from
here we can actually call the service
and we can put that message here
sign up
hello
let's write i have
signed up
and here i have signed
in
right everything is correct and let's
call
those functions from the service
this odd service
dot sign up
and this
odd service dot sign in
so
what it does is that it allows to keep
our controller clean
and only busy with the logic related to
the requests while our while our service
will be busy with the business logic
like connecting to the database editing
the fields etc so let's go ahead here
and do it again and we see that it works
as well and if we
launch sign in here
it also works now we know how a
controller works we know that it is
responsible for handling requests
we know how a service works or a
provider it is responsible for handling
the business logic but what would be a
business logic without connecting to a
database right so we need to somehow set
up a database and connect to it and by
that time i guess you have noticed it my
style of teaching is to introduce
concepts bit by bit so now we need a
database let's go ahead and set up a
database for that we are going to use
docker docker is an amazing tool that
will allow us to run our database
directly on our computer but so we don't
have to install it so it will run in a
containerized environment
i have docker already installed you can
go ahead and install it and one quick
way to check if it works you just write
docker ps and if it inputs something
that means that it's working
my version is
is version 20. with that being said
let's go ahead and and create our
database
so when i work with databases i prefer
to use docker compose docker compose
will automatically allow me to
spawn the docker containers and to
destroy them so it's very handy let's go
ahead and create docker hyphen composed
yaml so here's the configuration of our
docker compose i use version 3.8 in the
services we define
our docker container that we want to run
it's going to be dev db this is just the
name i i gave it to to it the image i'm
using is postgres 13 so we are going to
use the relational database postgres
version 13. it's going to be exported on
the port 5334
so if we connect to postgres 5334 on our
computer we'll be able to access it and
the environment variables i'm going to
use is the user rule is going to be
postgres the password one two three as
you have seen very secure and the
database name will be nest and it's
going to be on a network free code camp
that is defined here that's about it so
to to launch our database we go back to
our terminal we open a new one
and we do docker compose
up we choose the db that we want to run
so it's dev dv dev db
and we will run it in background so with
d
and that's it and we if we go to docker
ps we see that we have a container now
that is running
and we can even access a lock if we want
so docker logs
and it's written that the database
system is ready to accept connection it
has deployed it has compiled everything
is running correctly cool
let's go back to our app so we have the
database running in docker but how do we
access that there are libraries like
sqlize typeorm mongoose that allow you
to connect to the database in this
example i'm going to use a new orm that
i really love and i have been using for
over a year now it's called prisma so
you can access the website on prismo.io
what prisma is in a nutshell is that
it's kind of a query query builder but
it's so easy to use so basically you
define a model for instance that will be
a post with id title and all the fields
that you want in the database and you
can get
them from your javascript code or your
typescript with that syntax and we're
going to explore it straight away so
with prisma we are going to create the
database
connection logic the database module in
a way so that means that we need to
create another module since the database
module will be able to use to be used by
alt module because you need to log in
sign up it should be used by bookmark
module and even by user module so it's a
new
feature of our app for prisma we need to
have two libraries installed the first
one is the prismacy li it will allow us
to create our schema and run migrations
deploy the migrations into the database
so it's more of a maintenance library
and the other one is the prismaclient so
prisma has different clients the one
we're going to use is for javascript so
let's install prismacli yarn add and
we're going to add it as a development
uh package prisma
and yarn add
prisma client
for the client
okay let's clear that out with that
being installed we now have access to
the prisma cli let's run it
npx prisma init
and it's going to generate several files
for us first of all it generated this
dot nth file for the environment
variables and it just created a postgres
connection string by default that we're
going to change a bit later and it also
generated that prisma folder in the root
directory so what it has it just has its
schema and this is where we're going to
declare our models see when you use a
library like type or m you will create
entities and you will place them inside
your logic for prisma there's only one
place that you need to handle your your
models a bit like with a graphql
actually so you would declare those
structures that will describe the shape
of the data that will be in your
database right here it says that it's
going to use the prismaclient gs library
which we have installed the provider
will be postgres but you can have any
other library prisma supports mysql and
even mongodb and the url is the url of
the connection to the database so it's
going to grab it from the first
environment file that it finds so if you
place one inside the prism folder it
will grab this one for that tutorial
we're just going to leave it here in the
global
root folder and let's go ahead and
create our models so the way to declare
the models is just to type model
and you name it with a singular
word so if it's users it's going to be
user
and if it's bookmark it's going to be
bookmark right
model bookmark
bookmark and what do we have in our app
we have users and basically bookmarks
right so we only have two entities in
our app so the user will have an id
field
it's an integer we need to tell prisma
that it's an id
and we need to set a default as auto
increment
all that can be found in the prisma
documentation of course and same goes
for bookmark we also have to add the
created ad field
otherwise we will not know when it has
been created it's going to be a date
time and the default would be now which
means when the record is created in the
database a default value of now means
the time at the creation is assigned to
that variable and we also have to add
updated add i'd like to add that as well
datetime and prisma has a special
command here updated ad and we can copy
that to the bookmarks as well
right so
for the user what we will have well
usually we store the email of the user
it's going to be a string
and it's going to store also the
password at least the hash of the
password so we're going to put hash
string by the way if one of the fields
needs to be
optional you can just put the
so let's create two optional fields
first name
is going to be
an optional string and last name
optional string as well right we also
have a bookmark so the bookmark that
we're going to save is going to have a
title
is going to have a description
which could be optional
and we are going to have a link which
will be also a string but will not be
optional because when you save a
bookmark to a certain link well a link
needs to be there here we go we have
created our two models we see the file
and now you see it auto-formats it
nicely
then we need to add the
database connection string to our to our
database url variable here
so let's check it here so
the user is postgres the password is one
two three and the database name is nest
so let's go ahead and change that
user is postgres
password is one two three
the port is at five four three four
five four three four the database is
nest and schema public we can leave it
out like that so now when we run
prisma commands prisma will be able to
access our local database that is
running here docker ps by the way if you
have the docker app installed like i
have on mac here you can have you can
access the
the dashboard for docker and see your
container in action here an sgs api
tutorial and you can even see the logs
right so let's run our prisma command so
the way to do it is to run mpx prisma
and let's press help for get to get some
help so we have several commands all
that is explained into the prisma
documentation of course it's quite nice
by the way you can check it out so we
have several commands that will be
useful for us
we have the generate we have the migrate
and we have a studio studio will allow
to create a kind of a
online client so we can explore our
database through the browser we're going
to see that soon but the one that we are
interested at that point is prisma
migrate dave what it's going to do is
that it's going to read that schema and
it's going to generate the migrations in
that folder so let's go ahead and run
that
terminal
clear
npx prisma
and
migrate dev and basically says that oh
we you have added tables bookmarks and
users for those migrations to be applied
we need to reset the database and it's
usually common when you rise my when you
run migrate dev it's only for
development if you need to push your
migration to production there's another
command that will not delete the data
but for now we can just delete it and we
can press yes
and it's going to ask us the name of the
migration we can just say init
and now we see that it has generated a
migrations folder and basically it just
generated some sql
and when we run prisma migrate dev it
actually does two other things first of
all it pushes automatically that
schema that sql to the database so the
database if we go there and we check the
logs
here we see that
there's some command that has been run
insert into public users created add
email hash so prisma has already pushed
some migrations onto the database so the
database has the tables the tables of
users
and bookmarks and one other thing is
that prisma has also automatically run
the generate command so when you use
prisma migrate
dev prisma also does npm prisma
generator and what generate does
and it's actually a very cool cool thing
is that it takes your schema here
and it creates typescript types for your
schema so it creates the user
interfaces or classes
and same for model the bookmark
interfaces or classes so we can directly
use those
fields in our code so we can go
and now we see that we have a user here
the user
and the bookmarks as well that are
that are exportable as typescript types
from the prismaclient so we can use
those types directly in our application
which is awesome which is very awesome
we don't need to code that by hand we
can use it directly with prisma right so
let's come back to the schema and
inspect our database with prisma studio
so prisma gives us a very handy tool
called prisma studio we can execute it
by typing npx prisma studio
and it's going to connect to the
database at the url in the nv file
here we go at port five 5555
we are now at the prisma client and we
see that we have a user and a bookmark
modules right and we can go here and
inspect our database when we'll have
some some stuff there and we can even
add records if we want so it's totally
compatible with the prisma
schema it's actually quite cool let's
discard the changes for now and come
back to our code
we can leave that running that
that prisma studio running and we can
come back to our code here so far we
have created the prisma kinda migrations
folder and we have created the prisma
schema but we don't have any way from
our code to actually connect to the
database and for that we're going to
create a module to do it easily right
we're going to encapsulate all our logic
regarding the database in the module and
only export from the module the stuff
that we need to be accessed by the
application all right
let's go ahead and create a module i'm
going to generate i'm going to use the
nascli because i'll be quite lazy here
module prisma and i'll just call it the
same name as um as this folder but it's
of course two different things here
this prisma folder in the root stores
the schema and the migrations while this
one will be our module following the
nest gs modular structure right so we
will create an sg module prisma
and now it's here and we will also
create the service we have created the
service manually here let's go ahead and
create the service with the cli so
instead of module we have prisma oh
sorry we have service
and by default it is going to create the
spec files so the test files we don't
want that here so we say no spec
and now we have the
service
that is imported as provider in the
module right
and in the service we are going to
create our logic that connects to the
database so the way i like to do it is
that i like to have the prisma service
extending
the prisma client
and prismaclient is a class that allows
to
connect basically to a database right it
has a constructor constructor it has
connect disconnect
and execute sql and everything so what
i'm what i want to do is i want to
configure i wanna instantiate it
with its configuration so i need to
constructor and i need to call super so
super will call the constructor of the
class i'm extending and the constructor
of prismaclient needs to have data
sources needs to have db and url and the
url will point to that string in a
moment we're going to see how to use
config variables so dot end and
everything in sgs but for now let's just
put that hard coded into our prisma
service
right
and i think that from now we're going to
need a bit of more real estate to run
our scripts so instead of running every
time the terminal here i'm going to kill
it actually prisma studio as well and
i'm going to run my scripts in a
dedicated terminal let me make it a bit
bigger
so i'm going to do yarn start dev
and i'm going to split it
and do yarn
npx prisma studio and this is item 2 of
course it's a nice terminal i use on mac
so if you have any questions regarding
the terminal that's the
that's the one
let's go back to our code we have the
prisma service declared here
and we had it imported into the module
so
technically how it works in hds so let's
say we want hot module
to have access to the prisma module
because it's all modular right
well you could you would do something
like import
prisma
module
right
so let's see if that works all works and
normally you would have access to the
providers that are inside that module
right so let's go ahead and try it out
so in odd service
that is part of the odd module and that
has access to the prisma module now
because what module imports it in ort
servers we can use dependency injection
to get reference to that service to a
prisma service from our
old service code so constructor
private
prisma
and we can just reference it by prisma
service
let's press save and let's see what we
have oh we have an error well why do we
have an error it says that
nest can resolve dependency of odd
service please make sure that the
argument prisma service at index 0 is
available so what it does is that it
says hey you are trying to import a
a service here
and i don't know what is that i don't i
don't have access to that and even
though we have imported the prisma
module from the
in the auth module we have not allowed
the prisma module to export it to export
the prisma service to other providers so
if we want to do that we just need to do
exports
prisma service
right
and now the error should be resolved and
we don't have we don't have any error
right now so basically that means that
if you have a module here you will need
to import it in odd module to make it
work but that's a bit tedious because we
have our prisma module well the user
will need to have access to the database
the bookmark will need to have access to
the database and if we add two other
modules they will all need to have
access to that prism module so do we
need to really import that every time
like every time we need to create an
import and prisma model no
what is possible in
in
sgs is to create a global module so
instead of importing it like that what
we can do we can go into prisma module
and add another decorator called
global and just by adding that and
making sure that the stuff that we want
to be exported it also is also in the
exports array just by writing that this
prisma service will be available to all
the modules in our app and if we check
our
login everything works correctly just
make sure that your global module is
also imported into the app module into
the root module and in fact it is
imported here
now we can
really go and and do what we want and
here comes the interesting part because
this is where we really start to write
business logic this is where we really
start to do programming and not
configuration and if it was a bit
tedious to set all these up well
if you do something like that
properly with express alone it will take
you much more time and you need to be
really good with architecture to be able
to make everything work
flawlessly here well in sgs we have
everything working out of the box and of
course it takes a bit of time to get
used to the way of an sgs but in the
long term it's going to save you so much
time and here we don't actually need the
object so we can
delete it the injectable can
accept other objects but for now it's
not important in the scope of this of
this tutorial so without further ado
let's go ahead and start writing our
logic so for the sign up what do we need
the sign up is the creation of a user
right we need to create a user based on
something that we pass in the body
usually so usually it's going to be as
post route to old sign up we are going
to save to send a body to that route and
the body will contain the email and the
password and it's going to receive
something back uh about something back
we're going to discuss more into details
because we are going to touch to
authentication and especially gwt json
web tokens we are going to talk about
that a bit later right now just let's
focus on the
uh process between the request and what
is happening in the in the logic so an
sgs has a lot of decorators so this is a
decorator
this is a decorator right it has a lot
of decorators that that have different
functionalities remember i said that
under the hood is express gs well if you
want you can access that express gs
under the hood all you need to do is
write a decorator called rec
and it comes from nescs common and let's
call it rec and we give it a type of
request which comes from express
actually so you need to be a bit careful
about that
where things come from and
if we now press and if we now console
log rec
we will see that rec will have a lot of
properties and those properties
are actually coming from the express
request object so let's just lock it for
for the loads
and call the odd sign up
i have signed up amazing let's go back
to our locks here and we see that we
have logged the request object and that
request object is basically
the same as the express request object
and you can get stuff like headers
like body
etc right so if we wanna lock the body
it will be something like request body
and then if we want we can pass that
body to the sign up function so let's go
ahead and request the body
and provide the body of course it's
going to be form url encoded
here we have an email and a password
let's send it over and let's log that
into the console and we see that the
body has been locked now usually how it
would work is that we will pass the
request body inside our function and of
course here it complains because
it
the sign up doesn't doesn't have any
declared parameters but
what happens if the email is not defined
if the password is too weak or even
there's no password well this process of
validating that is called the validation
and sgs has a lot of tools for that to
make it really easy to do but before
even going to
to that direction i want to point out
that this method is not very clean every
time we need to get a request and then
we don't have any
any information of what is inside the
body and sgs uses dtos data transfer
objects in a nutshell is just an object
where you push your data from let's say
a request and you can run validation on
it if you want and you can even have the
shape of those dtos because we use
typescript so we can say that the body
should have an email and it should have
a password right so let's go ahead and
implement that when working with nsgs
you should never really use the request
object of the underlying
underlying
library because what if you switch to
fastify what if you switch to another
framework that they might add in the
future you will use that kind of
independence that nest yes has you will
not be able to reuse the same code
pretty much so what we are going to do
is that we're going to use another
decorator it's called body and it just
allows us to get the body of the request
right let's call it dto
and let's declare it as any because
right now we don't know the shape of it
and let's console.log that dto
and i'm going to use a
my favorite logging
pattern so basically it's just going to
create an object
and put the detail inside it and that's
a shorthand for that let's go ahead and
do the request again
and you see that it also works
so the advantage of using decorators
like that is that express will get the
right body
depending of the framework for you so
you don't need to really worry where the
body is in express or fastify or any
other framework
netgs does it for you right but here it
only
brings us half of the answer because we
don't know the shape of it so we need to
create a interface for that shape let's
go ahead and create it so usually i like
to create a folder called dto and inside
the dto i use the baron export pattern
so i have a index.ps that is going to
export all the fields
so here we are going to
do what while it's going let's call it
alt.dto.ts
and it's going to be interface called
auth
dto
it will have an email which will be a
string and it will have a password which
will be a string and we need to export
that
all right we need to close that and
we're going to index and we need to
export that detail from the index
and if you have never seen that pattern
the baron export pattern the main
advantage is that now i can just do auto
dto
and it's going to import
all the details from that folder instead
of doing something like
alt dot dto ps and if we have something
else like signup.dto.ts
instead of doing that it's going to
import everything from the same folder
all the imports will basically be
there in those brackets instead of being
spread out
in your in your code right
so that's a nice pattern that i love
using it brings a bit of more code but
honestly it's worth it it makes your
code much readable and now we have
access to those parameters email and a
password in the dto right and let's
let's clean it a bit delete the request
here we go let's try it again
and it works again
but here it's only typescript so what if
we don't pass the
email what if we
we forget to pass the value to the email
well if we log that
we don't have any errors we we have
email that is void and we have a
password so that's a problem because now
we need to write codes like that if dto
dot email
if not then
throw error and this is very verbose we
can simplify that a bit by using the
class transformer and class validator
libraries so let's go ahead and
implement them
and just before we implement them let me
introduce pipes
what are pipes in sgs pipes are just
functions that transform your data so if
you have a string that comes from the
request because usually apart from you
if you send a json if you send a string
in the in a in a query something like
sign up
for instance user is equal
one or
user one that one will be a string and
if in your code you need to use a number
that could be a problem so one way of
doing that is to use the built-in pipes
so what we can do is that we say email
it's going to be a string
and we can isolate the email field
directly from the body like that
and the password would will be
will be
created like that right
and let's
let's log those email password
and for some reason my print here is not
working see this line is a bit big so
i'm going to go into print here and
reduce a bit the the print width
and you try that out
okay 50 works well
and let's also lock the type of
type of email which will type of email
and same for
type of
password type of password
so again i
go here and we say that the email is a
string the password is a string so what
if we want to
transform the password into a number
well
it could be
done simply like that by using inline
pipes parts and
pipe and there are other pipes but
usually it's the this one that you're
going to use and here since it's not a
number the password will throw an error
so it's going to stop the execution of
our code and if we check here there's no
console.log it's going to stop the
execution of our code before
even we run the the business logics so
this is amazing but if the password is a
number well it's going to have it's
going to work right now and we see that
here the password has been converted by
the pipe to the number obviously this
process is a bit verbal because you need
to create a pipe
for every
data field what we can do with the dto
is just
is just apply
those transformation and validation
directly
on the on the dto
right
so let's go ahead and continue what we
were doing with that small explanation
about what are our pipes but i think
it's quite important to understand the
pipes before we move into the dto
validation
so there's more explanations about pipes
in on the nsgs website and you see that
we have different pipes bull pipe
floatpipe uuid
which stands for unique
unique identifier but there's something
called class validator so basically this
is what we need we need to install those
two packages class validator and class
transformer so let's go ahead and add
them
yarn add classified editor and class
transformer
here we go and now what we can do is
that we can go into the dto
and to apply the transformation and the
validations we need to
use a class not an interface basically
it is the same for us it doesn't change
anything it's just that instead of
interface it's a class
and we need to add
something here is email for instance
from the class validator package
and
is not empty
and it's going to be and this is going
to be a string
and it's going to be is not empty
and let's go ahead and
throw the request again
and we see that it does not work right
why didn't it work well simply because
we don't tell an sjs to use the pipe
logic to use the validation pipe
globally everywhere so we need to go
into the main.ts
and just before the app.listen right up
use global pipes
and here we just write validation
pipe and validation pipe is a built-in
pipe by cs for that same purpose right
and we need to instantiate it like that
new validation pipe
so now that we have added that
validation pipe let's go back to the
insomnia and run the request and here we
see that we have two errors the first
one is email should not be empty and
email must be an email right so that
that's cool so if we provide something
like test well it's still going to
complain that it must be an email so
vlad at gmail.com
and now everything works this is
validation in a nutshell thanks to dtos
the validation pipe can do other stuff
such as transform automatically your
data one thing that could be interesting
for you guys is to see that use case so
i'm going to my controller and i'm going
to console.log
ddto
and if i'm going to
execute that logic we log that but what
if i try to cheat what if i have
identified a maybe a vulnerability in
your new server and i want to inject a
variable for instance id is equal one
or or any other variable well if i
console.log that id will be passed to
our dto and maybe that's not something
that we want right one other thing that
the piped validator can do is that it
can strip out the field that you don't
need
what we can do is just set white list to
true and it's going to do
right we send the same request
and now we see that the id is not here
what it is doing is that it's stripping
out the
element that are not defined into our
dto so now we can be sure that rdto has
an email and a password and no other
fields that we haven't defined so this
is amazing
let's go back to our controller now
and write the rest of our logic now we
know that the dto is validated and it
has an email and a password let's pass
it to the sign up function to make it
all clear
clean that and let's open
the
ordered service
and in the odd.service
here the signup function will receive a
dto of odo right
and now we can run our business logic
with self-assurance that the data that
we receive from
the client from the browser is actually
correct so the first thing that we're
going to do is that we need to generate
a hash
based on the password i like to use
arkhan so a lot of people use bcrypt for
password hashing and that's a fine
solution but i also have the refresh
token in my in my application and
there's a problem with bcrip because its
verification algorithm is only limited
to the first 72 bytes argon is
considered to be a better solution
overall so i'm going to go ahead and use
argon
for that we need to install arkon 2
and we can import it into our old
service
so all as arkhan from argon 2
and the first thing is that we need to
generate the password
then
save the
new user
in db right
and we need to return the user the saved
user
we're going to do those three things
first
so let's generate the password hash is
equal argon
hash
the first will come the plain text that
we want to
hash so it's going to be dto.password
and that's it
then we're going to save the user in the
database so const user is equal a weight
and it will be in a sync function of
course because it calls prisma
asynchronously
this prisma
user
and since we have defined user in our
prisma model
create
data and this is the data that we're
going to use
to create the the user with and what we
have here we have email which can be
dto.email and we have
hash which will be
that hash
right we can save it and it's not happy
because it says
promise string is not assignable to type
string and of course argon hash is in a
sync function so await
and the user is created and then the
user is created we just returned the
user
let's go ahead and and create our user
so we can go back to insomnia delete
that id and create the user
and our user has been created obviously
we see that we have returned a hash
which you should not return because
that's basically the hash password of
the user not very secure and let's let's
try it out again so we go to prisma
studio we
can reload and we see that the user has
appeared here we can delete it
delete record here we go and go back to
our code and just say that huh listen i
don't wanna return the hash
or how do i do it with prisma well
prisma has a lot of possibilities either
you
you create a select and you select only
the field that you want for instance if
we want only the id we say id true email
true
and for instance created add to true so
it will only return those fields
like that
and let's go ahead and delete that but
obviously it's not very handy because
there's a lot of logic to
to write right so what i prefer to do is
to write transformers
so we are going to cover that topic a
bit later but for now an easy and dirty
solution would be to do delete
user hash so it's going to just strip
out the hash
out of that user object and return that
so let's go ahead and create one and we
have the user object without the hash
amazing right
so one other thing that will be
interesting what happens is that i if i
send the user again well if i do it
again it's going to be created again
another user and another user that's
because email field is not set as unique
in the prism so let's go ahead and run
the migrations to set it unique
and we can delete that otherwise we'll
have some problems and let's go ahead
and
let's get back to the prisma model and
this is how migrations of prisma work so
those migrations have created the
bookmark and the user now we're going to
modify our model
and to make it all compatible with our
database so we can simply include the
new updates to our database
what we need to do is we need to modify
our schema so for instance email should
be unique
we might want to rename the
the table user to users because right
now it is created user it's good for
prisma because prisma prisma loves those
kind of things but we're going to just
map this name to another name so
map
users
and
map
bookmark
everything seems to be correct amazing
one thing that we might add as well is
the relation between bookmarks and user
so bookmarks will belong to the user the
way to do it with prisma is to create
a link
to the user in the bookmark because many
to one connection so many bookmarks
can belong to one to the same user
in other words this user can have many
bookmarks but any given bookmark at any
given time belongs only to one user and
not to several users so many to one
let's create a user id
variable it shall be a nint
and
user
it shall refer to the user model
we need to tell it it's a relationship
it's going to use fields
so we use fields to indicate to prisma
which fields are used for primary keys
and we use reference to indicate to
prisma to which variable this primary
key references to so it's going to be to
the id which is an integer of user so we
just name id right
amazing right so we have made some
changes and prisma automatically
included an array bookmark here we just
need to change it book
marks
and it's going to be an array of
bookmark model
all good so now we have made our changes
we need to run the migrations how to do
it we come back to the
terminal
and we do npm prisma
migrate dev
it's going to connect to the database
enter the name for the new migrations
let's just name update
models
it has run the generate so it has
generates the new
variables in typescript for bookmarks
and
for user id and it has made the email
unique and also has pushed the new
migrations here into the database we
might need to restart studio
sometimes it's it's a bit buggy when you
run the migrations
and
it works correctly so now we have the
user and with the new fields email
should be
i believe it should be unique somewhere
it should be written unique but anyway
we have bookmarks here
and the bookmark has been updated with
user
id
and the user object so which is which is
really nice let's go back to our code
and
write continue writing our logic so we
go back to the odd.service let's see if
our logic against the duplicate user
works so we create one user id one
because we have reset the database
and if we create the same user with the
same email again what we have is a 500.
not very cool right because 500 errors
don't tell us anything about what
happened
it's better that we provide to the user
a kind of a specified error saying look
in that case it is a forbidden exception
because um credentials is already taken
right so we need to create that error in
sgs it's actually quite easy to do and
if you see here in
in the logs we see that the
there's error with the
unique constraint failed on fields email
so prismas tells us that email is unique
and we cannot really use it
so
what we can do is that we can say
we can try catch
block so we put all that into the try
catch
error
here we can just isolate if the error
comes from prisma or not so if error
instance
of
prisma
known client request error and all that
is detailed in the docs right
the only time where you would
write those detailed
uh error exceptions
is basically when you create unique
filled with unique properties basically
you don't need to
cache all the possible prisma errors
here i just want to make sure that if
i'm caching the
prisma duplicate
unique duplicate error so if the error
is is a prisma error and not something
else if that happens if error.code
is equal to
p2002 which stands for duplicate field
like
prisma has error codes defined and this
specific code
stands for you try to create a new
record with a unique field that has been
violated so if that happens we throw a
nes gs exception throw
new
forbidden
exception
credentials
taken
right and that new forbidden exception
actually comes from
from sgs
it is well documented in the docs and if
the error is not
does not come from the prisma what we do
is that we just throw the error right
and let's go back to our
insomnia send the request and here we
see that the status code is 403 and we
have a descriptive message error message
telling to the client hey the
credentials are taken you cannot use
that amazing right
so we have created the sign up service
function so let's go ahead and create
the sign in so what happens when we sign
in well the user will provide the
password and the
email the first thing is that we need to
find the user
by email
if user
does not exist
throw exception
then compare passwords
and if password
incorrect
we throw an exception
and if everything goes well we just
send back
the user
okay so the sign in function will also
receive the same dto as the sign up we
don't really have a
difference between the sign-in and
sign-up process in some application they
do in some application they sign up
object the signup detail will be more
complex but in our case it's going to be
the same so the first thing is to find
the user so we go and find the user
const user is equal await this prisma
user find so the way you can find
elements in prisma either you find them
by find unique
or
find first
so if you want to find a single element
from the database using prisma you can
either find it with unique or first
find first will allow you to get the
element by any field and find unique
will allow you to get the element by
unique field so in our case either a id
or a field with unique property
so let's let's use find unique
where
email is dto.email right so the first
thing that could happen is that
someone tries to log in with an email
that does not exist in our database so
to handle that use case we're going to
create what's called a guard condition
so if
not user
we're going to stop the code at that
point and throw an exception pro
new forbidden exception
credentials incorrect
and if the user has been found we can
just continue our logic and compare the
passwords for the password comparison we
are going to use
the
compare function of the argon so for the
compare password
pw matches is equal await
argon
verify the first argument will be the
hash so the hash password it is in the
user of course so user.hash
and the second argument is the password
in plain text and it comes from the dto
dto.password here
and again we put a
guard condition if
not
pw matches if password does not match we
fire an exception the same exception as
above
here we go
and if everything goes according to plan
we can send back the user and before
sending back the user we can delete the
hash
field on the user object
that looks good now before we go ahead
and try it out
let's create some handy scripts for us
so
first of all let's just write a script
that will allow us to respawn our
database instead of typing it manually
here in the terminal let's create a
script in the package.json so we can
just run it and it will rebuild our
container for us so our postgres
database and the second thing is that
let's also write a script that will
allow to apply those migrations to the
database so let's start by the database
so
let's let's call let's call the scriptdb
dev
restart so that means restart the
database with the dev development
environment so by definition we only are
in development but if you have a project
and that has several environments such
as testing environment maybe staging
or something else well you can create
several scripts with that syntax
so for now let's go ahead and first try
it out our script here so docker
composer so to remove a container and
here in our docker compose our container
our service is called devdb
to remove it we use rm and let's go
ahead and see what what functionalities
we have here so we have force to
to remove them without asking us for a
confirmation we also have stop to try to
stop the containers before removing them
it could be nice it's a nicer way of
stopping them still just killing them
and we also have this v
dash v to remove the volumes attached to
that containers and that's a good thing
to do so to for our
cleaning script is going to be docker
compose remove dev db
as
f
v so let's go ahead and put that into
our
maybe let's do something like that let's
let's split our logic into several
subscripts so it's just easier to manage
deb db
dev
rm
right
and the same would be
db dev up
but instead of removing it's going to
to push it to to create it and with and
it's going to be done in background
and for the db dev restart script it's
going to do yarn db
dev
rm
and yarn db
dev
up
let's try our our newly created script
in our terminal and see if everything
works correctly yarn
db dev restart so we see that it runs
the first one and then it runs the
second one
so we have the remove
thing here and we have the
creation of the new
docker container here and if we do
docker ps
we see that we have one
created here for us
the problem though is that even though
we have created the database it doesn't
have migrations applied to it so it does
not have tables
of
users and
bookmarks
so we also need to create a script to
automatically apply the migrations so
remember in the beginning we have run
the command prisma migrate dev what it's
going to do is that is going to generate
a new migration
based on the current migrations and we
don't really want to do that what we
want to do is that we want to apply
those existing migrations
to to the database so that process is
much more safer than regenerating the
whole migrations every time additionally
when you do prism migrate dev it asks
you for for confirmation and it asks you
for a name of that uh migration for
instance we have init here and we have
update models so it's very hard to
automate however the other script that
prisma has is called npx prisma actually
let's go ahead and check the migrate
docs help
and we have my grip dev that's the one
that we have used in the beginning to
generate the initial schema and to run
the migrations but if we just need to
apply the migrations to a database we
can just run prisma migrate deploy so
let's go ahead and create that script so
prisma
dev
deploy
so it's going to deploy the migration to
our
dev db which is here at that at that at
that link
so and so prisma
migrate
deploy
right
so
and what we're going to do is that as
soon as the database is up we're going
to run that script as well so it's going
to also deploy our current migrations to
the database that we're working with
and
yarn
prisma dev db what might happen as well
is that if you have a slow computer the
database might take a bit of time to
start so it's usually nice to put this
bit of sleep here i'll put sleep one
second
so we are sure that before trying to
apply those migrations
our database is running and everything
is set up correctly so we don't try to
apply the migrations on a database that
is in bootstrap mode
so let's go ahead and try that out again
yarndb restart is killing the database
it's restarting it it's waiting a bit
and it applies the migrations here
and we we see that it's written that we
have we have found two migrations and
the following migrations have been
applied here amazing
now we can go ahead and start our server
and thanks to typescript we now know
that we have an error amazing we don't
need to
run the script at runtime to note that
we have an error we have it here even
before starting the server so
we have what we have
in the odd controller
you have not given a dto while in the
service you require a dto let's change
that
so in the service the sign-in function
it requires the dto while in the
controller
you don't pass it so let's copy the body
here the body logic and pass the dto to
the sign-in function that should resolve
the issue amazing now we can come back
to insomnia by the way i noticed how to
make the font bigger i don't know i just
didn't think about it but yeah basically
there's an option in the
in the in the adrenal options where you
can resize the font so sorry for the
smaller fonts in the beginning i'm
learning as well let's go ahead then and
do the sign up request so let's send it
and we have the user if we try it again
we receive an error
and if we do sign in and provide the
same credentials we have the user again
if we do a mistake with a password
we have an error which is nice and if we
do a mistake with the
email
we have an error as well amazing
we basically have implemented the sign
in function and everything works
correctly
one thing though in real applications
when you sign in of course this
information can be sent
to the browser so it can
it can for instance render
information about the user but it is not
enough to help the api to help the
server to actually identify the user
connecting to to it we see that in our
case we send the email and the password
and it's called basic authentication but
we cannot do that every time right so
there are some apis where you need to
send the email and the password and
basically anything required by the basic
authentication at every api request
encoded maybe in a base64 format that
might be a bit technical but that exists
but in our case for the user experience
we want the user to log in only once in
a while right
so to allow the
server to track the user to know who the
user is there are two techniques the
first is sessions you probably have
heard about them already and the second
one is gwt json web tokens and that's
another way of of tracking the user on
the website so know who the user is and
allow or forbid the request based on
user identity because if the user sends
that back it's not enough of course
anyone can fake that this whole process
is called authentication and
authorization right so we authentify the
user so the user
provides some credentials we know who
that is we authentify then the user but
then we need to give something to the
user
so we can authorize that user
through subsequent requests for instance
login signup everyone can call that
route right but there might be something
private for instance
user
slash me and that only
authentified users can call it so let's
go ahead and implement that
functionality
as i said before we are going to use gwt
for that we have already prepared
modules for an sgs now so far we only
have seen
custom made modules so it's modules that
we have made ourselves but next gs also
has modules that you can use in your app
like any npm library so let's go ahead
and implement some of them
the first module that we're going to
implement is the config module so for
now we have used hard coded environment
variables so this database url
we have actually hard coded it in prisma
right so instead of doing something like
that which is not secure at all because
that will be available in your github
repository
and
also it is error prone because what
happens if you do an error here right
it's very hard to notice and it can be
only detected at runtime efficiently so
that's something that we're going to fix
with the config module so let's go ahead
and install it
we can kill the server and install yarn
add
nest gs config
and we can start the server back again
and let's go ahead and implement that
config module so the config module is
usually implemented on the root module
so here or you can put it in a in a
custom module and implement it there if
you need to use something like uh
validation on that so for instance you
can check
that oh this variable should be a string
this variable should be a number this
can also be
checked
but it's out of the scope of this
project so let's just leave it out but
know that you can actually put the
config module inside a custom module
called config if you want but for now
we're going to just import it here we
have just installed the config module
let's go ahead and implement it config
module and and you see it comes from an
sds config i actually like to move all
the node modules
packages on top
now config module requires some
configuration and if we
and it requires a for root option
and that's all we need to do to load
that dot n file into our application
under the hood the config module uses
dot nf library i actually have a nice
video about dot n on my channel so if
you are curious how it works check it
out like any module that we have here it
also have a service and it also uses
dependency injection so we can import
that config service
inside any of our modules of our app so
where do we need it well at first we are
going to need it in prisma so let's go
ahead and use it in prisma to use
dependency injection don't forget to
annotate a class with the injectable
decorator so if it has injectable
that would be able to use dependency
injection you don't need to put inject
injectable if you don't have any
dependency injection requirements so if
you don't use something like
prisma
prisma
service for instance
if you use that and sgs will complain
somewhere
for instance prisma
user
find
many
if we do that it should complain because
it's going to
try to get that object and that will be
undefined so it will not know
what the user is and in fact it says
cannot read property of undefined right
so for any class in sgs to use
dependency injection and that class of
course needs to be inside the module we
need to annotate it with injectable
decorator so now it will work
but of course we don't want to use
prisma that was an example what we want
to use however is the config module so
let's go ahead and name it config config
service config service is a service
declared in the config module that we
have imported here i'm just repeating it
so you guys
can
absorb the new
the new concept easier right repetition
is key
and what i'm going to do here is that
this string now i'm not going to
hardcode it i'm going to import it from
the dot and
file and the way the config module
exposes that dot n file content
is by
having getters
in the on the config object so this has
is a config object we can do
config
dot get
and we just name the
the name of the variable and database
url
let's put it in quotes
clean that and fire it up
and now we have an error saying
basically that okay we know what a
config module is but the config service
is not
exposed well that happens because
by default all the modules i kinda
contained so this config module would be
only available in the app module but
will not be available into the
prisma module so it's very similar to
what we have here
with global you can expose our prisma
module to the whole app while any sgs
compatible module also have this
functionality of course we cannot use
the decorator
here but inside this object there's an
option called as global so we can just
enable it and that basically does the
same thing
let's come back and now it should work
to make sure that our prisma service is
working correctly with config
we can go ahead and print the config
and we see that
we get the right
url so everything is working and let's
test it out let's create a new user
vlad2
amazing the new user has been created
and that proves that our logic works now
let's come back to the gwt the subject
of authentication seems to be quite easy
right like how hard can it be you just
log in and sign up come on every website
has that but in fact under the hood it's
very very complex and there are
companies multi-million multi-billion
companies
if i'm not mistaken making hundreds of
millions of revenues per year providing
that service to corporate and and
and companies so that's a quite edgy
subject to get it right is also very
hard
so in this example i'm going to provide
a very simplified functionality very
simplified authentication if you need to
get more information about that i have a
two hours video on that subject alone on
my youtube channel it's about netgear
gwt authentication if you are interested
check it out
but without further ado let's get
started and dive in and try to add
authentication to our cloud app
netgas has some decent documentation on
authentication and authorization
and behind the hood it uses password
passport is a
authentication framework for express gs
with a lot of strategies so you can
log in with facebook login with google
od0 twitter
gwt and has a lot of functionality that
you can use in our app in our example we
are just going to
use
gwt so basically the user will give the
email password pair and it will receive
a gwt what is a gwt i have a video on
that on my channel but basically is just
a
string with a signature some data and
some description about the kind of
string it is and which algorithm it is
using and basically inside it is a
json that is encoded in base64 and this
is the information that the server could
pass to to the client so for instance in
our case
we could pass that this sub which refers
to the id will be a an id of the user
the name could be vladimir in my case
and the email could be vlad gmail.com
and you can add as many
claims as you want so all those fields
are called claims there's the expiration
you can put an expiration we can put a
creation date
basically yeah you can put any data you
want and you pass that the server
creates that when the user logs in or
signs up and it passes it back to the
browser so every time the browser goes
somewhere on the application it sends it
over to the server and the server says
okay yes or no you have access to that
or not this behavior is quite similar to
sessions except that sessions are being
passed automatically
with each request while gwt needs to be
passed
basically with code but apart from that
they solve pretty much the same problems
or at least people use them to solve the
same problems of course some might argue
that gwts are bad for authentication but
i don't necessarily subscribe to that
point of view if people are using gwt
for authentication we should at least
show them how to do it correctly
so let's go ahead and install the needed
packages we need to install quite some
packages if you have any problems with
following the steps of course all the
code will be uploaded on github in the
description below this video but
without further ado let's let's proceed
and install all the needed packages
so what we need to have we need to have
nsgs passport
module we need to have passport and
passport local we don't need passport
local is a library to handle local
authentication so we don't need passport
local nor do we need the types we only
need passport and
an sgs passport this is basically the
passport library and this is supporting
tuna gs kind of a
a
a module for an sgs for passport so we
need to install those two
let's kill it and yarn at
those we also need to install gwt
specific libraries so here nextgs gwt
module and pass for gwt package of
passport
so it's a bit a lot of libraries to
install but don't worry you just follow
the steps everything is going to be okay
and we also need to install the types
for those for gwt
thing because in no library and they
don't have typescript inside the
repository it's in another repository
and we're going to save it as a
development dependency
here we go
yarn add
d for development dependency and types
password gwt
now we will have all those added here
somewhere
right and let's see how we can use them
in our application
first of all everything regarding
authentication of course goes into
authentication module and that's nice
thing because everything will be
organized and clean in our project
the first thing
that we need to import is the
gwt module so
remember what we have installed this
gsgwt is basically used to sign in the
code tokens this
under the hood uses json web tokens
library so it's just a kind of a net gs
modularization of that library
while the other one in the beginning
that uses passport this is a true kind
of module that pours passport to an sgs
so
the reason why i'm i'm saying that is
that this we are going to use it in our
service while the other library
we are going to kind of put it in
another folder called strategy because
the first time you see that kind of
pattern it's a bit weird so
we're going to import it
here gwt module
so this is to sign and decode
the the uh
the recent web token and we just need to
register it
and there are several ways to do it you
can provide
uh some uh the secret because the gwt
needs to sign with a secret you can
provide it here and expiration dates and
stuff like that i usually like to leave
it blank because in most of the use
cases here we're not going to use a
refresh token but most of the time when
you deal with
gwt you also need to
use a refresh token and the refresh
token will have a different secret and
expiration date from the
um
from the access token and more about
those in a minute but that's why i kind
of like to declare the module here and
customize it further into the
old service um
provider
right so we this is to sign in the code
json web tokens so let's uh let's do it
now let's do it first we go here and
since it's a module because everything
in ngs are kind of modules it also has a
what a service of course well we need to
import it again with dependency
injection and this gwt modules is
registered inside this module so it will
be accessible here we don't need to make
it accessible there and the use case of
that model is just to sign
some tokens so let's go ahead and do it
we need to import it here as a
dependency injection so private gwt gwt
service
right and this is imported from
gwt from the same package and if you
have any dot you can also just check the
package and see what's what's there
there's a gwg service gwc module and
some interfaces
and i think it's actually a good
practice to always kind of inspect a bit
the
the libraries that you use it will allow
you to get a better understanding of
what what is inside instead of just
blindly following documentations and
see things just appearing there out of
nowhere
so we have sign up and sign in well we
said that we don't need to return a user
we actually need to return tokens
but to return that we need to sign that
information though like this user
information
and transform it into the token
obviously like here so we need to
generate something like that right based
on
for instance data like email and id so
let's go ahead and create a function for
that this is going to be
sign token
and i like to put it in a sink as well
and this sign token will take the field
that we need to sign it's going to be
user id which is going to be a number
and a email which is going to be a
string so we're going to send the user
id and an email so later on when he
passes back something like that we can
get those two information out of that
token and run validations or assume that
oh this is the user at id one so
whatever action that he does on our
platform check first is that he has
authorization to pass that specific
action and then perform that action so
this is the kind of information that
we're going to extract from the gwt
and kind of trust what's inside
so we're going to construct an object
that we're going to sign
let's call it data
user
let's call it sub is user id
sub is just a standard of
of the gwt
kind of convention that
that you need to use a unique identifier
for
a subfield and let's add any field that
we want for in our case it's going to be
an email
and what we're going to do is that we're
going to return
this gwt
sign and all those functions come from
json web token library that you can find
on npm if you need
sign a sync
and the first thing is going to be a
payload and the second
the second argument is going to be a
options for the signature and this is
where we can set our secret secret
information that we're going to sign the
data with so only us know that
information so if a user comes back with
a token hw token we know that it comes
from us because we have signed it with
our secret password
and actually we can name it payload
because it's going to be more
descriptive
payload and the second option will be an
object first of all we want to set when
that token will be expiring so let's set
it at
fix 15 minutes
15 m
so that means that once we give that
token to the user the user can do some
actions on our platform for 15 minutes
after that the token will be rejected
and the user needs to sign in again
and we also want to add the secret of
course secret is mandatory otherwise we
cannot really sign
and for the secret since it's a secret
we should definitely not commit it to
github let's put it into the nv file as
well
let's call
secret
and let's name it whatever like super
secret
and let's copy that and use the same
process that we have using to prisma
prisma service let's import the config
module
private config
sorry config service
and let's get that the gwt here
const secret is equal this config get
gwg secret
here we go and since we're using
typescript we can actually provide some
interesting
function descriptions like the return
type is going to return a string
right and
here
and for sign in for instance instead of
returning the user what we do is that we
return this
sign
token
user.id
and user.email
perfect
since we return an asynchronous function
we don't need to put a sync here this is
only useful if we do some asynchronous
operations when with a weight here since
we're returning the promise we don't
need to put it here um the code will
know that it's a promise and same thing
happens here and we don't even need to
delete the user here we can clean that
out
and let's also return
the user
here
awesome let's get back to our insomnia
and pass the request so now if we do
sign in
it's going to return us
of course we forgot to start the server
silly me
the server is running no errors let's do
the request again
and now we have a text
which is not very nice though i didn't
really want a text
but it gets us the the json web token
and by the way if we copy that and paste
it here into gwt.io website we see that
we have the sub which is the user id and
our email
so this information that we have signed
is correctly included into the body now
into the next part one thing that we
might to add is that instead of
returning a string
because here is going to return a string
and of course nsgs is going to convert
the headers to
text.html i'd like to return a
object so instead of doing that we can
just change the logic a bit
here in our sign token we can
return an object
with access
token
i have noticed that usually the
convention for access token is to
have this snake case convention and we
can
just return the
access token
here
like that and of course it's going to
complain because our type now is
incorrect
our type is promise string so it should
be promise of
object access token which is a string
now everything is working correctly and
if we execute the sign-in again we get a
object with the access token key
amazing
now on to the next part the strategy
part we have generated a access token
basically a token a user can use to
pass requests protected requests to our
application the next step is to actually
write the logic that will be able to
intercept that token
so that token that we the user passes to
us
validate it make sure that it didn't
expire and make sure that the signature
with which we created the token is
correct and then only allow the actions
that the user want to do on our platform
so to summarize we have written the
logic that allows us to create a token
right it returns a access token to the
user
then what would happen
well the user will call another route
for instance
users
me to get the information about the
current user and he would provide in the
headers an authorization token
something like that bearer
space and that would be the access token
so the logic that will verify that this
bearer token is correct is called a
strategy and this is what we are going
to implement now
for that we create a folder in odd
module called
strategy
we'll create a baron export
and we'll create the strategy which is
basically just a class
strategy.ts
the strategy
ts
export class gwt strategy
we have an example in the next gs
documentations let's check it out
here the strategy should extend the
passport strategy
which comes from the nsgs passport
module and it implements the gwt
strategy which comes from this passport
gwt library and what it does is that it
configures it in the constructor calling
super so it calls this module this
service it says that the gwt should be
extracted from the headers as a bearer
token so it just means that it should be
you should have this kind of format
bearer space token which is a standard
for
a bearer token
this property is set to false by default
so we don't need to set it to false it
just allows us to ignore the expiration
date of the access token which can be
useful when we are testing but we don't
need it at that point and it takes the
secret key as a as a parameter and the
secret is basically
this thing that we have defined here
we have signed our token with a specific
secret
well we need to allow the strategy to
decode that same token with that kind of
secret not really to the code but more
to verify that the signature of the
token has been really signed by that
secret so we know
that
the token comes from this server from
our api so let's go ahead and implement
it the gwg strategy should extend
passport
strategy
that comes from nsgs
module passport
and it should take the strategy
that comes from passport gwt right
and it has a constructor because we are
extending a a class we need to call its
its constructor
the constructor of the parent class like
that
and we need to provide the configuration
of that of that passport strategy class
so we can just go ahead and copy what is
there
and delete that because it's false by
default and
import extract gwt and x and this is
basically the
the secret right so this class is also a
provider like the odd service class
right so it can use injectable the
reason why we separate it in a different
folder is just to make sure that we
don't we know that this class has a
specific use case and it's for
validating
the um the token the access token so
that's why it's inside a a folder but it
can also use dependency injection under
the hood so that means that it can
inject prisma inject gwt and inject the
config and this is what we need because
we need to get that
that secret from the environment
variable so let's go ahead and do it
injectable
and
here is going to be config
config service
config dot get
and it's going to be
i think we called it gwt secret every
time i forget how we call things
gwt secret amazing now now everything's
okay the only thing that we need to do
is that we need to export that class
from our baron export which is a good
pattern and we then need to import that
strategy as a provider so nsgs is aware
of that of the strategy being part of
our application so cheat which is
strategy
and that's all we need let's go ahead
and start the server
nice everything seems to be
correctly
instantiated and we now have the gwt
strategy configured now we can protect
some of our routes with that strategy
that means that you can access a route
only if you have a valid strategy here
we are using gwt but if you want you can
also have strategies like login with
facebook login with google and they have
their own configuration options and
stuff like that so again we generate the
token with the odd service and then we
have a strategy that we can decorate
other routes with so only people with a
valid
token can access it but we don't have
any other routes any other controllers a
part of the odd controller so let's go
ahead and create one in the user module
i'm going to use the cli
nest g controller
user
i would name my controller users based
on the rest api format and let's go
ahead and implement a simple get
endpoint is going to be get me
if you leave get decorator blank
it will
it will catch any any requests
so it will catch any requests
like that
if you put something there
it will actually catch it with that
pattern so if you leave it blank it will
just use the pattern of the controller
to catch it obviously if the controller
has nothing it will try to catch it at
root which is not a very good idea
because it can have conflicts and
undesired behavior but in this case we
are going to use me so we are going to
call that endpoint with users
me
and in me we are going to
return something return
user info
it's just a string right right now we
are not doing anything
and if we go back to insomnia and call
users me
and let's actually delete that
and it's not a post request it's a get
request
it's going to return us user info
because we have just mapped that route
onto our application but we haven't
protected it right so there's a
so so to protect a
an endpoint to
kind of have a condition that will say
okay if you meet certain conditions we
are going to execute that that logic
else we are not going to execute that to
do that in sgs we use what we call
guards and again you can use the nsgs
documentation to read about guards a
guard is basically a
function that will stand in front of a
route handler so in front of the end
point and it will allow or not allow the
execution of that endpoint in our case
our guard would check
for the strategy and if the strategy the
gwd strategy is correct is going to
allow the execution of the route if not
is going to block it you can of course
create custom guards but in our case
we can use something that has already
been pre-made and that comes from the
nsgs passport module and it's a node
card so to use guards on a given route
or on a given controller you can use
pretty much everything at a global level
at the controller level or you can use
it at the route level so in our case we
want to block the get me route if you
don't have a valid
token so let's go ahead and create that
we need to use a decorator called use
guards
and in the use guards we can provide the
guard that we want to use
and the net gs passport the module that
we have
here somewhere
actually here
an sgs passport it already has a guard
for to work with that strategy right so
it if we inspect the code here we see
that
what do what does it have it has a note
card it has some interfaces it has
passport module but this is what we are
interested in it's a north guard and
basically so it's basically a guard
that
is compatible with nashia that we can
use and that works very well with the
strategy so
let's come back
let's go back to the user controller and
import it here into the use guard
decorator so alt guard
and here in the parenthesis we provide
what kind of guard it is what kind of
strategy it is guarding for so it's gwt
and when we create our strategy with
with that with that strategy with that
uh strategy object that comes from
passport gwt it by default assigns the
gwt kind of key to it so so you can
assign any key that you want
for instance for instance gwt2
but by default it just leaves it like
that so it will be identified by the odd
guard with that keyword so if you have a
refresh token you can do something like
that you can name it really the way you
want you can
give it any name that you want but by
default it's gwt you can leave it blank
or you can leave it here gwt i will
prefer to leave it like that because
it's going to be clear it's going to be
a bit less of magic because the first
time i encountered the odd guard i was
wondering how does it know that this gwt
is
linked to that
strategy and that's how
so
we are going to say that oh this route
should be protected by that strategy
now let's go into insomnia and try to
use the same request again
and see we have a 401 status
unauthorized
well it's because the strategy is being
executed and it does not receive the
bearer token so it throws an error so
let's recreate a bit the flow i clean up
the database i have now three routes get
me route a sign up and a signing route
so let's go ahead and sign up
and
create a
body email vlad
gmail.com
passport sorry password
one two three
and um
let's create the account we have an
access token that access token
we can use it in our bearer token so if
we if we throw the request in right now
if we use a request right now we're
going to get a 401 because we haven't
required any we haven't given any better
token let's go ahead and implement it
authorization
bearer
and then we paste the token and now we
have another error which is interesting
let's see what is going on
this validate is not a function okay we
forgot one function in the
in the gwg strategy and it's validly
date so let's go ahead and
write it
[Music]
and it's going to take a payload of any
and let's lock that payload
cool one important thing that we forgot
to implement is that we forgot to have
validate function so the token is going
to be transformed into that object
and put into payload and then we need to
return it
so
here we can perform any validation that
we want and then we can return the user
in our case we are just returning the
json so what it's going to do by
returning the payload is going to append
the payload to the user object of the
request object it sounds a bit confusing
but under the hood of nsgs we use
express right and we can get the request
and the response of express with the
right decorators we i have shown it in
the in the beginning of the course right
what the gdwt strategy does it's going
to append
dot a user
[Music]
object to the request object so we can
use it in our route so the user is going
to be that payload so it's going to be
that object with the sub email
expiration date etc let's get back to
the strategy and just run it again it is
passing correctly right so we have the
the console log the payload here as i
said it's an object with a sub
uh of the user id email our email and
other information that was contained in
the token right so let's clean that
and let's see why
is it useful for us well if we go back
to the controller
i said that the strategy will put that
decoded payload or whatever value we
pass here whatever value we pass in the
validate function is going to append it
to the user object on the request
object of the request of the of the the
api so
we can get that object here
request
actually rick rick
and the rec object is from sgs and
request interface is from express
and we can do console log
user is equal to rick.user
wreck.user
and you see that even express knows that
a user is possible because because when
you validate the identity of a user its
identity can be
appended to the request object so here
we are going to
log that
it's going to log the
payload so the object that we have
returned from here so if we
run the request again we come back to
the thing and we see that we now log the
same payload but from the controller
because we have written
user here so if we pass any other
value here
let's say hi
well
hi is going to be
logged
here because we basically attach
whatever we export from the validate
function to the request user object
right does it make sense if that doesn't
make sense and don't worry about that we
are going to build upon that concept and
i'm going to come back to it
a couple of times so basically that
means that we can get the information of
the gwt
from the token and do something with it
since we have an id we can get the user
by advertising since we have an email we
can maybe get the user by that email
everything is possible we just know who
that user is
that requests the user's me endpoint
let's clean the strategy and
return the payload
we can close the strategy file and come
back to the user controller file
so what we are going to do now is that
we need to get the information of the
current user
based on the access token right
so now we need to get information of the
user and return it back so
that can be done in a several ways
in that example we are going to get the
user object
from the database directly in the
validate function so on top of having
config we also need to inject prisma
prisma
service and here we can get the
the object so it's not going to be any
it's going to be
it's going to have a subfield which will
be a number and it's going to have an
email field which will be a string
validate will be in a sync function we
can get the user const user is equal
await the prisma
and i forgot to put private
the reason why i don't put private in
front of the config is because
if we do something like that
i can't really
use this because super must be called
before anything
and since i'm not using config in my in
the rest of my application there's no
point to use private and remember when
we use private is just means that we
declare the variable here automatically
right so we don't need to do that we can
leave it without private and of course
it's going to be
config.get but here we can use private
because we use it elsewhere
so this
prisma
user
find
unique
it's going to be where id is equal
payload.sub
also very important thing to notice is
we if we return null
it's going to throw an error
right so the user will be null if the
user will be not found an a401 error
will be returned and if the user will be
found that user object is going to be
appended to the user request object
on the request and the thing that we can
do before doing so is to delete the hash
so we don't inadvertently export some
sensitive information and then we return
the user and in our user controller what
we can do is that we can return
rec.user
now if we run the request user
slash me we're going to get back the
user based on the
access token and now we have our
application working we can sign in sign
up and get the information of the user
so that's quite cool
but there are a couple of things that we
can enhance
before i told you that you should not
use the request object
immediately because it is error prone
and this is correct so we can fix that
and we also can make that a bit more
clean so this is easier to do so let's
start with that every time that you need
to put a string somewhere it's called a
magic string it can create errors and we
can make that cleaner by abstracting it
in its own class so let's go ahead and
do that
this functionality will be part of the
odds so let's go ahead and create a
guard a custom guard
so
new folder guard
and again the baron export here and we
are going to create the gwt
guard dot ds
and what it's going to do is going to
just be a class gwt card and all we need
to do is to extend the odd guard
and we are extending a guard with gwt
strategy
and that's pretty much it we might just
run the super
and
and we need to export that class so we
can use it in our application so instead
of writing odd guard
like that with those strings we can just
write that class and let's export it
and import it in our
user controller
gwt guard
and if we run and if we check the
runtime it is executing correctly and we
can even get the information correctly
oh 401 unauthorized and we can
we can
so
so this is similar to what will happen
in our application we get a access token
for a specific amount of time and once
it is expired you cannot use the
protected route anymore so we need to
get a new one
so let's go ahead and create a
request email vlad gmail.com and pass
word
one two three
we get the new access token and then we
come back to the
to the header here and replace it with a
new one
and if we send the request it works
correctly
so now we have fixed that and let's go
ahead and fix this
this is a decorator so you know all
those things are decorators we have made
a custom guard that extends the
odd guard provided by
an sgs passport but we can also make a
custom decorator that will go in the
request object and get that user object
and return it back to us so now you can
go in the odd folder because it's kind
of part of the odd
old functionality right we can create
another folder called decorator
and again export the baron with the
baron export and let's create a custom
what we call a
param decorator and i don't remember
this syntax by heart and obviously
that's why as programmers we have
documentation so you use it when you can
you're not supposed to
know everything by heart and in the
custom decorators documentation we have
param decorators and um that basically
mean that you can put them in the
parameters of your endpoints and there
are a lot of them already defined you
see that you have the request that we
have already seen there's session as
well you have ip headers query body that
we have used right
and they say that you can create a
custom decorator for instance to get the
user object on the request object and
the way to do it is like that so let's
just copy it
and i'll explain in a minute what it
does so let's go and create our
decorator let's call it get
user
decorator ts
and let's call it get user
and that's it it is creating the param
decorator that we can use like that
get user right and it in fact it only
knows it
and what it does is it can take a data
that you pass to it for instance
that would be data
but by default it's unknown so you don't
you don't need to pass it and the second
argument it's actually gets
it actually gets the execution context
of the request so it's important to
understand that an sgs is an abstraction
right it uses something under the hood
it can use express it can use any other
protocols here we say that the this
execution context switch to http because
we're using http but sometimes you might
use for instance web sockets right
or you you can use rpc for something
like like micro services in our case we
use http
and then we say get request there are
other things that you can do you can get
the response as well but here we want to
get the request so it's going to get the
request object of the express
library right
and
then we can do something with it so this
request will actually be the same as
express
request
if that makes sense right
this request is going to be that and
then it's going to
return whatever we want from it so the
decorator will put in a variable
here
whatever we return to it and it's going
to be a user and in our case since we
have used a strategy in our case the
user object will be the user object from
prisma right that's all we need to do
for the custom decorator let's export it
from the baron export
file and in the user we want to use the
baron export pattern it's going to
export it from the decorator
file and here
we don't need to put any data for now
we're going to leave it blank and here
user is going to be of type
user and that will come from the
prismaclient so in the beginning of the
video i said that prisma generates
typescript typings for us so which is
very cool so now we can say that this
variable is of type
uh user that was defined in our prisma
schema
and now we can
just return the user and it makes it all
clean and that decorator you can reuse
it pretty much everywhere
now
we can also optimize that logic a bit by
moving the guard on the controller's
level so that just means that everything
that is in the user controller well it
will require you to be to have a token
it will require you to provide an
identity of who you are which makes
sense that way we if we have another
endpoint here for instance
patch
edit user
well we won't need to copy the guard
here as well we can just put it on the
global level
so let's go ahead and run our request
again and everything is working
so let's say that in dark in this case
you don't really want to pass the whole
user object you you just want to pass
the id so you can say i just want the id
and then it's going to be user id and
it's going to be a number
so you can say something like that and
then in your logic you can get the id of
the user if you want to do something
like that it's quite easy you come back
to the get user decorator and you say
well if if data if there's something in
the data
then you return
request user
data and data will be a string
and it could be optional
so we if we don't provide it it's going
to
return the whole user object if we
provide it it's going to return
the
the uh
a field from the from the user object so
we can we can actually try that out here
and here we say we want to get the email
of the user
it's going to be a string
and we can before returning the user
console.log that email
let's run the request
and if we come back here
oh there's something that's not working
working a required parameter cannot
follow an optional parameter
let me go back to the get user and here
okay i see so instead of doing like that
and this is true a optional parameter
can only be put at the end here the on
order kind of matters so we will say
string or
undefined
so that way the data could be
potentially undefined let's go back and
throw the request
and we have a log of our email and the
same time we get our user so everything
is working correctly let's clean that up
and we don't need to get the email
anymore
so thanks to those tools decorators and
guards we have created quite a clean
logic for our application you see
everything is quite organized and
everything has its place there are a lot
of decorators that nest gs has and it
allows basically you to save some code
and have something
well i would say ergonomic from a from a
visual point of view for instance
there's another decorator that i use
quite a lot and that i haven't showed
yet it's
http code so usually when you create a
resource on the server you send back a
201
http code so if we go ahead here and
create a new user
vlad2
the status code will be 201 right so
that just means that the server has
created something in a database that's
kind of a standard you can of course
make it return 200 so for that it's
going to be http
code
that's the decorator and inside the
decorator we're going to return the
status so for instance it could be 200.
and sjs also has a num so instead of
returning numbers which is error prone
you can return in nums http code
http status and you have
accepted
found and it basically means different
codes so code 200 means ok
so and if we
put the mouse here we see that 200 is
equal okay and there's a lot of other
codes that is that are used in the
development so you see here's a whole
list here not found for instance that is
very known 404 401 autumn to rise that
is thrown by this strategy when the bear
token is not correct and forbidden for
instance 4 or 3
when we throw a forbidden exception
so we can do that
obviously when we create a user now it's
going to be
200 but by default a post request will
return 201 so we don't really need to
change that however when we sign in we
don't really create any resource so i'd
like to return the code 200 so we can
use it 200 here so instead of like
signing in with a 201 it can be used to
sign in and get a 200. so that's quite
cool so post requests return usually 201
get requests will return 200 so we don't
need to specify a http code decorator
here
we have implemented quite some features
already and you see that our application
starts to grow we'll soon implement the
user
or routes for instance the patch user
route will also have bookmark routes and
our application will start to grow and
it's going to be very tedious to
actually go in insomnia and run all
those kind of tests manually imagine you
have something like 100 endpoints and
you need to test several use cases for
instance like oh i sign up with a
profile of admin and the admin should
be onboarded and then it should do that
and then i need to sign up with you oh
my god it's it's pretty much impossible
to test
manually so that's why we use automated
testing
there are three kind of main
levels of testing you have unit testing
that you probably have heard about unit
testing will usually
take any any functions for instance it's
going to take
the signup function is going to mock any
dependency that the signup function is
using for instance argon or connection
to the database and it's going to try to
make sure that this function is
executing and
calls the right the right things and
everything is working correctly on that
unit
level however that takes a lot of time
and to make it right you need to
actually practice a lot there's a lot of
methodologies how to do unit testing and
it can be really nice when you have a
project
where a lot of people work on and a
product that will spawn through years
and years of development unit tests are
a good
investment in terms of your time
however in most of the cases what we
want to have really is end-to-end
testing and integration testing so we
have unit testing just above we have
integration testing integration testing
will kind of take several modules and
that's why nsgs is so cool because by
default it separates our application
into modules so for instance i want to
check the odd functionality only well i
can load the odd module and the prisma
module and maybe the config module and i
can test only all those three together
and when i'm happy with the result i can
just test something else user a user
well for the user will need to have a
user so it needs to use the odd module
so we're going to use the odd module
user model prisma module but not the
bookmark module and we kind of can test
all those together integration testing
you define some segments of your app and
you test them together i like to test it
with a
test database so on top of having a
dev db that i use for like manual
testing and manual feedback i will also
have a testdb
here in our docket compose that i'm
going to spawn and destroy every time i
do my tests so you have integration
testing and then you have end-to-end
testing and end-to-end testing kind of
verifies a very high level user journey
of your app so okay user signs up signs
in he requests his profile he does that
so it mainly verifies how the user will
interact with your app while integration
testing we can really test a lot of
things for instance well is the sign
token working correctly is if the
sign talking with sign-in is working
correctly are the exception throw
correctly
so
this is more for integration testing
since testing takes a lot of time
usually it's
estimated that testing takes at least
the same amount of time that you have
spent on creating your app so if you
have spent something like two weeks
building your app you'll probably spend
at least two weeks testing it there are
various methodologies for testing
there's test driven development where
you
write your app as you test obviously we
have not done that here and it can solve
some problems as well but in our example
here in our small crowd application what
we can do is that we can use end-to-end
testing so end-to-end testing will allow
us to
kind of showcase the use of our app and
prove that it kind of works we don't
need to go into details and make sure
that everything works together if you
are interested by that you'll probably
be using integration testing i have a
video about that on my channel so if you
are interested about that specifically
and how to do it with prisma
well be my guest there's a one hour
video on the subject but in our example
we are going to use end-to-end testing
and i'm going to use a library that has
been suggested to me by one of the core
developer of nsgs and i have to say it's
quite cool it allows you to save a lot
of time and it's called pactum by
default nsgs uses supertest
for the end-to-end test but in that
example we are going to use pactumgs
so
without further ado let's get started
and create our end-to-end test so we
don't have to jump between our code and
insomnia over and over again okay so
let's start with that amazing endeavor
and first of all let's install
pactum
yarn add
pactum
so pactum is an amazing library for
testing your apis
it is really nice to work with and it
works very well with graphql and it has
a lot of features that we're going to
use straight away and to install it all
we need to do is to use
is to install it with pactum
so before we start our test we'll need
to consider a couple of things first of
all we will have to set up a test
database for our end-to-end tests
because we want to keep the dev db
actually separate from the testdb so we
don't delete our database every time so
that's one thing and the second thing is
that we'll have to set up the database
set up the prisma service to be cleaned
up every time we run our tests
but before doing that let's clean up our
app end-to-end spec file
we can just go here and delete
everything so how nas gs works is that
it's going to compile a module
and we're going to take the whole global
module the app module is going to
compile that and we can create a test
module out of it
and on that test module we can call
requests like we do with insomnia
so let's go ahead and first create a
describe blocks so it's going to be
app end-to-end
and inside that app end-to-end we will
just run a test
a to do test
should pass
just to see that if our script is
running
and we are going to kill our server
because we don't need the server anymore
we are going to kind of use what we call
test driven development we are going to
write tests and write logic and make
sure that our tests are passing
so
the way to run that file
is through test end to end here there's
a script already created for us by ness
gs so yarn test end to end and let's see
if that at least works and we see that
we have a pass test nothing really
happened but that's fine because we
haven't
uh defined our test yet so let's go back
to our test and create the prisma module
so before all the tests
what we're going to do and it's going to
be in a sync function it's kind of a
hook that is provided by jest we're
using jest as our main testing framework
those describes come from jest and we
are going to use pactum for
for the requests
to send a request to our server and to
analyze the the answers to responses
from the requests
so before doing that we need to create a
module const
module
ref
a weight test
the test is going to
come from
from
nest testing
next yes testing
there will be a test
test create testing module and here we
import and that's basically a
a module as we have
here in the app module so we create a
module that will import that app module
inside it that's the easiest way to do
it
app module so the app module comes from
the
from from here
and we are going to say compile and
that's pretty much it for the end-to-end
test we just import everything because
everything needs to work together
and what we need to do then is to well
let's see that passes to begin with
right
amazing
now
what we can do
is to avoid every time that every time
that we want to run the test to avoid
that we have to go here and do yarn test
entwined we can set the test to be kind
of automated
so the run automatically as soon as they
detect a change in our code so we go
back to packer.json and
say just watch
one important thing that we need to
say as well is to disallow the cache
of the test in case we don't run in the
problems where some resources might be
cached so that's fixed as well let's go
ahead and run it and see if that works
so now it should be running continuously
and if we
save
nothing would happen but if we run a
new test
it should automatically recompile it so
it will detect if we have any new tests
in our application and if i press a it's
going to run all the tests again that's
pretty much just you usually just i
would say flow you press w to get more
options but for now that's all we need
to do
and let's delete that test and
and see if we can
connect to our test database right now
and let's add a couple of things
basically what we are doing here is that
we are simulating the
this server so anything that we have
defined in the main ts we also need to
define here
in our testing module here we use global
pipes if we don't
include those
the
dto validation in our test will not work
so we need to also include those just
before
here so now that we have the module
compiled we need to run a we need to
create a nsgs application testing
application so we can say app is equal
module dot ref
create
module ref
create nest application right so it's
going to
try to emulate an app um
here it just compiles the module that
can be useful when you run integration
testing but since we really want to run
an end-to-end testing we need that also
app we can abstract it in a in the
describe here
i
nest application
and app will be this
and
now we can include the pipes
otherwise the the validation pipe will
not work it needs to
be as close as possible to our real
server
and at the end we say await app init so
this is where we kind of start the
server
and when we're done when all the tests
are done what we do is that we do app
close so we close the app
and
we see that now it is still working
everything is good
this is our
starting logic this is our teardown
logic we can close that
and now let's think about the database
well
by default nest cs
in our case will connect to our dev
database we need to have a dedicated
test database for our test and a
dedicated dev database for everything
else so how are we going to do it first
of all let's create the dev db in our
in our
docker compose so
just copy here and code
sorry testdb
db
is going to run on port
five
and
five four three five so it should not be
running on the same ports otherwise you
will have a problem
and the rest can pretty much stay the
same
we can now go back to the package.json
and we see that we have a
um we have the scripts for the dev db
right well we need to have the same
scripts for testdb
so let's copy that and
write it here test to be restart so
and
and just copy all the scripts here and
those will be for test
prisma test deploy
db
test
remove ntb test up
so
for the test tv it's going to be just
test to be testdb
prisma deploy
and
here in the tb restart is going to be
test
remove yarn db test up
and yard prisma test
deploy
okay
one important thing though is that um
prisma does not manage the
the environment variables by default so
here is going to just load
the environment the database url from
the environment file that it detects so
i need to be a bit more specific here
this means that prisma will try to find
that variable from the environment
variables and if it doesn't find it it
would try to get it from the nv file so
one thing to work with prisma with
different environment variables because
you can't just create another dot in the
development dot in dot testing that
would not work well with that the
cleanest way i found to manage
environment variables with prisma is to
use a npm package called dot nth cli so
let's go ahead and implement it
yarn add
the 10th
cli
so what is going to allow us to do is to
inject the
end file of our choice in our kind of
scripts
so by default if we
just stay on the environment variables
it's going to get
this environment variable so if we don't
do anything everything is going to be
loaded
immediately from this one right
however if we
if we want to use another environment
variable such as
env
test
it's a bit more tricky to force or our
code to use this one because prisma will
automatically only get d.n it doesn't
know about dot n.test and it cannot know
about it the config model from the api
tutorial can load that specific one for
instance it has a variable called end
file path and you can specify where the
environment variable is but we'll have
to create a lot of filler code and it's
going to be quite ugly so it's better to
use the 10 cli it keeps our code clean
and we don't need to change anything
here we just need to include that
library here so let's go ahead and do
that so if we are using the dot n
development
we don't need to
use the 10 cli because by default it's
going to be using this one and this one
will overwrite any any other environment
variables file however if we use the
test ones we need to inject this one
first so
it's very easy to be honest you d you
just do dot n dot e and you just provide
the
path to the end file environment file
and dot test
and then you just execute the rest this
is this is specific to docker so docker
doesn't need to be aware of the
environment variables however when we
run our test we also need to make sure
that the net gs is loading the right
the right environment variable not this
one but this one
and for that we also need to include
here so we include dot n
hyphen e dot and the test
on the test end to end
and on the
deployment of our migrations right and
let's come back to dot end of the test
and just
let's just clean that
here
and
implement that new string
but instead of the port 5434 we are
going to have the port
5435 which is
the right port
now to test it all and this is the
moment of truth
let's go ahead and kill it and do yarn
test end to end also
an important thing is that we need to
create a hook for test end to end so
when we
run the end to end test it needs to run
the db test restart so it's going to
clean the database the test database and
it's going to
push the migrations on that test
database and it's indicated in the
end.test and to define a hook in
package.json scripts so we just say pre
and we put the name of the script here
so if we execute that this is the hook
that's going to be executed before
and we do yarn
db
test
restart
and just to make sure that everything is
correct db
test restart okay let's try that out and
see if that works
so we see that the hook is working
and everything seems to be
correctly working now to make sure that
the migrations have been pushed into our
testdb
so let me just open a new terminal
session and i just do docker ps
and we have now two
databases one that has been created just
just now and it is the database on port
5435 it is our test database and this is
the old
dev database on port 5434 so what we
want to do is to make sure that this
database has a migration
all we need to do is to use prisma
studio but remember that prisma is also
using this dot end file so what we can
just do is
to force prisma studio to use this one
with the same technique that we have
used here so uh dot n e f test let's
copy that
and it's npx because we are running it
from the terminal
and we do prisma studio and that should
automatically connect us to
to the right database now we see that
the studio is blank however if we
connect
to the to the other one with dot nth
we will be connecting to the dev
database and here we have some fields
that we have been testing with insomnia
so everything is working correctly we
can clean prisma studio we won't need it
for our tests and let's come back to our
testing logic if you have any questions
regarding that process feel free to drop
them in the comment section below i will
try to answer as soon as possible but
all the code here will be available in
the github repository in the description
of this video so if you are stuck
somewhere just check there and i'm going
to clean here because
everything works correctly and
yeah let's start our testing process so
now we're connected to the testdb via
this environment file everything is okay
let's go back in our
in our testing module so what do we need
to do first well first of all before
running our tests
we need to make sure that the database
has been cleaned and of course every
time we run our end-to-end tests the
whole database is actually restarted so
cleaned and restarted but
when we run our tests in the same kind
of
js session we also need to clean the
database we don't need to restart the
docker container because that takes time
that takes like three four five seconds
and we don't want to wait all that time
all right so what we want to do is that
we want to tell prisma to clean
everything that is in our database
every time we run the tests right so
because we have a
just end-to-end
session that is watching so that is keep
going it doesn't stop
we need to do it
manually so it's quite easy to be honest
to do it
but let's first examine our schema to
make sure that we are doing the things
right
so what should happen here well every
time we do we run our tests we need to
delete the users and the bookmarks and
sometimes there could be a problem where
for instance the bookmark is linked to a
user right but what happens if you
delete the user first well if you delete
the user first the bookmark certainly
might be without a user and that could
be that could be problematic because
that can uh
create errors to make sure that we don't
have any errors and
that elements are deleted in the right
order we can either tell prisma to
delete first the bookmarks and then the
users but that can be a bit daunting
because imagine you have something like
20 models so your tier down logic of
your database can be quite long or you
can do something like that you can say
on delete
and we just say cascade that means when
the element that is it is the kind of
the parent of that when the parent model
or that bookmark is deleted
the bookmark should be deleted as well
to implement that we need to run
migrations i'm not going to do that i'm
going to go with the other option where
i'm going to make sure that the bookmark
is deleted before the user but know that
it is possible and in some cases it is
really good to have a
on delete cascades and it's unless you
really want to conserve the data
in your database so for instance you can
in an app have categories and pos let's
say that the user decides to delete a
category well you can say what happens
with the posts in that category are they
kind of
set to are they just do we keep them or
do we delete them as well in our case if
a user has been deleted the bookmarks
should kind of be deleted as well i
don't see why would we keep the bookmark
so undelete is set on cascade
but
in some application you might want to
keep the user data you know you never
know but
know that it is possible to have those
kind of hooks on prisma but i'm not
going to go with it because i don't want
to run the migrations i'm going to just
show the other way
the other way is to go into prisma
service
and we need to implement a new function
let's call it clean
db and what does clean db well we need
to tell it what it does
and we need to delete the bookmarks and
the users so we can do return this
prisma sorry actually
user it works like that because this is
actually prisma so this is the
prismaclient
user delete menu
so what do we need to have here we need
to delete all the users and we need to
delete all the bookmarks
and of course since we need to do it in
order it needs to be first bookmark and
and user right except that prisma kinda
optimizes our
our request and could delete the user
before the bookmark so to avoid that we
can use transaction a transaction is
when we tell prisma to make sure that
the things are done in the specific
order so this
transaction
and we just provide an array and
elements will be executed one by one so
we first need to delete the bookmarks
and then we delete the users so we don't
have a case where a bookmark can be
without a user
and we just need to return that and
that's it that's all we need to do
this is our tier down logic that we need
to run before
our end to end test and let's come back
to the end-to-end test in before all
hook we need to make sure that in that
logic the database is reset so how do we
get the database well it's actually
quite simple in sgs because it uses
dependency injections so you can do app
prisma let's just declare our
prisma service here
and now we can say
we can say prisma
is equal to app
get and we can get any provider that we
want
it's called prisma service
and it's going to just get that prisma
service and we can put that into the
variable and we can call that variable
like that await prisma
clean db so it's quite cool to do tests
with an sgs because it's yeah it's just
a nice experience and we can come back
here and we see that property clean the
b does not exist on type prisoner
service that can happen sometimes
when
you write code and you didn't allow
nsgs to recompile the files so in our
case we i think we need to just
restart the server and that should work
so if you are doing major changes to the
underlying logic to the services you
might actually need to restart
the end-to-end test because it needs to
compile the the files into into
javascript right and that's it and let's
go ahead and now create our end-to-end
logic we can close that collapse this we
don't need to touch it anymore and we
don't need to touch it either because as
soon as we close the app the prisma
connection to the database is also
closed so we are quite happy now let's
create our test so describe
odd
what do we need else we will have
a user
and we will have bookmarks
so you notice that i actually write the
tests first before we even have a for
instance bookmark logic is because that
will allow us to kind of have a
structure already and think about our
application before we even build our
code so what should be in the od well it
should be
sign up
and there should be
sign in
and that's pretty much all there arrays
then we should be able to
get the user
get current user
or more like get me
then we should be able to
edit user
and for the bookmarks we should be able
to
get bookmarks
create bookmark
[Music]
we should be able to get bookmarks
we should be able to
get
bookmark
by
id maybe edit bookmark
and delete
bookmark
because that way
we'll have our crowd
application
now sgs complains because we haven't
created a single test
um
let's go ahead and just
create a to-do
i think it will be happy with that
should sign up
let's see if that works okay that works
so
we have should sign up we also have
should sign in
and let's start by that so this is kind
of our testing structure now we're going
to run our tests write our test actually
and for that we're going to use pactum
so to run the tests with pactum we first
need to import it with import all
aspectum
from
pactum
so after that we have imported pactum we
can now use it in our application but
pactum is a request making library it
needs an api it needs to server to make
requests to
and so far our servers are an sgs app it
just has initiated the nest application
context we also need to start a server
by providing await app.listen
and we can provide the port at which we
want the app to listen and now we can do
the request so we can go into our first
route
a to do
and
we can provide a callback function to
that test
and what do we call we call
return pacton
spec
and then we provide the the request type
is a post request to odd
to http
localhost
3333
odd
sign up
and then we need to provide a body as
well with body
and the body will be the dto the odd dto
and it will take an email which will be
vlad.gmail.com
and a password which will be one two
three
and we will provide that email here and
we shall expect a status
of 201 because we are creating our
resources so let's get back and see okay
perfect that test took 42 milliseconds
and that has succeeded if we want to see
what's inside the request body we can
just
call inspect at the end of the promise
chain
and the body here has been logged along
with the code and the headers so you see
that we have the
headers that is powered by express the
status code is 201 and we get our access
token
now this is a bit verbose because every
time we're going to call the
the api we need to write that this is
called also the base url so what we can
do is that we can abstract that away
from this post request so we don't need
to repeat it in a subsequent request so
we can do pactum request
set base url and we can just provide
that base url and instead of writing the
localhost here we can just write out
sign up that is much cleaner much
shorter and that does the same effect
let's get rid of the inspect to see if
our test is passing and everything is
nice so it just took a bit more time but
it just independent of our of our logic
okay now it's amazing ddto we are going
to reuse it in our whole odd application
kind of odd uh flow so we can just move
it above
and
let's also test if the sign-in
route is working so we are going to
delete the to-do here provide a callback
to be to the test
and return alt signin
since it's a end-to-end test it will
first execute this code so we will have
a user and then it's going to execute
that code and obviously it should be 200
and let's see how it works
amazing everything works together so we
have tested that we can create a user
and that we can sign in usually when you
write the tests you also need to test
the use cases where
your test will will fail right so for
instance before writing should sign up
we should actually write
it
should
throw
should throw an exception
if email
empty
so we can also write all that to test if
that logic will will throw so we can
just copy that
put it here
and say that we expect a
a code of 400 so we're going to write
400 status code to be expected because
we expect the error to be thrown by the
validation pipe which returns a 400
error bad user input and we also need to
provide a dto without the email so what
we're going to do is that we're just
going to provide just the password one
two three actually detail the password
so we reuse that
that dto and let's see if our test is
passing and we see that the test is
passing next we can also check the other
way around so should throw if password
password empty
so instead of having the password here
it's going to be email and it use that
email and should also throw 400
right
and
we can also test
both
just in case
throw
should throw if
no dto
nobody
provided
and i'm just going to do it without the
body
and we can do pretty much the same with
the
with the sign in so we can copy that and
test it with a sign in here
except that it's going to be
sign in
everywhere
let's go ahead and check our tests
and everything is passing and that's
pretty much the process of
kind of end-to-end testing it doesn't
really test how our
modules how our functions interact with
so
we might return the right status
but maybe
some something in the database is not uh
it's not saved in the correct format and
that we are not going to be able to
verify that with end-to-end testing
end-to-end testing it's not the it's not
um designed for that end-to-end testing
it's just there to make sure if the app
is working end-to-end so if kind of all
the functionalities are working more or
less as expected if you need to go in
more details you're going to actually
create integration testing and that's
out of the scope of this tutorial
now a very interesting um part is that
we need to check the user information
right but for that we need to send
the
bearer token so pactum provides a very
neat functionality that allows us to
store a variable in the
pactum execution context
so we don't need to create a variable
somewhere
for instance we don't need to
do something like that
access
token and then assign it somewhere else
based on the
of what our api returns what we can do
is that we can use the store
api of pactum so here in should in let's
inspect
the body um response that's going to be
returned so we have the
body and we have the access token so we
can actually save that value in the
memory of of pactum so let's go ahead
and use that functionality and it's
basically a stores
function store spec request and response
data and we can choose where what we
want to store so for instance it's going
to be user 80 user access token it's
kind of like assigning a variable and
the
the path to that variable will be access
token so it's going to
get the access token
from the body the access token variable
from the body which is in the json and
it's going to put that into that
variable and later on we can reuse that
variable in our request so let's um
let's do it here
get me it
should
get current user
return pactum
let's just copy that
here
and we are going to
put users
me
and it should not have a body however
it should have a
a authentication headers and if we check
the code right now
let's rerun that
we see that
get current user we have a status of 404
that's interesting
why is it
what is going on with it so users
has that
controller and me
users me so why is it not working that's
very interesting
404 cannot post ah it's a post request
of course it expects a get request so
get
and now it says that it's
it's 401 unauthorized because we don't
have the access token right so let's get
go ahead and pass the access token in
the same way we have passed them in
insomnia remember here in headers we
have
um
we have authorization bearer space and
the access token let's go ahead and do
that here
headers
with headers
and we can provide the object key value
so the key is authorization
and the value is bearer
and to inject that variable that we have
saved here
there's a special syntax in pactum and
it is
this thing a bit like what we have in in
template strings with javascript except
that you have an s here for store and
you can put the name of the variable
here and normally we should get a
a correct answer and we can even inspect
that to make sure that we get the
correct one
and you see that we got the user object
that was expected in a nutshell that's
all integration testing is most of the
time you will just test if the status
code is correct and at that point we
have tested all our routes and what is
left is to actually write the logic for
edit user and write the logic for create
bookmarks get bookmarks get bookmarks by
id edit bookmark actually by id and
delete bookmark by id so this is what we
are going to do in the next part in the
next section we are almost there we have
almost finished our crowd application so
what we need to do now is to create the
logic for the patch
request and the crud request in the
bookmark module let's first start with
the patch request
and we are going to need the service
here we can leave our end-to-end in the
background
and we can go ahead and create our
our service so nest g service
user
no spec
it's going to create a service for us
that we can now use
let's put it there
and we need to create a function here
edit user
in the same fashion that we have done
with the odd service so edit user is
going to be probably in a sync function
it's going to take several fields it's
going to take a user id
and that's pretty much it
and it also needs to inject prisma
[Music]
prisma service
and
that's yeah that's about it so once it
receives the user id it also needs to
receive a dto and it's going to be a
edit user
dto let's create the dto
so edit user
dto.ts
and it's a class edit user dto and what
can we edit well we could edit the email
we could edit the first name and the
last name so email
string
first name
string and last name
string
and all those fields can be optional
because we can just edit the email
without editing the first name or the
first name without the email etc right
so we can also provide the class
validator is email
this is going to be a string
string
is
string
and all those are going to be is
optional
is optional is optional and we need to
export that edit user dto and export it
here through the baron export pattern
from
edit user dto
let's
clean those files and come back to user
controller
the patch request
edit user will receive a body
of type edit user dto
and it's going to also get the user
and just the user id
so
id
user id and it's going to be a number
and it's going to call the
function in the user service edit user
and it also needs to have vdto edit
user dto and let's just call that so on
that side on the controller side this is
done return this
um
oh we have of course not imported the
the user service here we also need to
import it through dependency injection
private
user service
user service
and now we can use that user service
here return this user service
edit user user id and dto
on the controller side it is now done
let's go back to the user.service and
write our logic here so what we need to
do is to update the user with the dto we
know that the dto will either have an
email first name or last name so we can
trust the dto
because remember we have this
function
we have this pipe with whitelist.true so
we are sure that we are going to receive
at least
something
at least something in
in
in our in our api request
and we can
say user sql await this prisma
user update
where
id
is user id
and the data that we're going to update
we just can just destructure the dto so
if the dto has something it's going to
be structured here
and before returning the user we can
delete the user dot
hash and return the user
that's our edit logic and before
continuing any further let's go back to
our test and run the test for that edit
edit functionality so we come back to
our tests we have
where is that we have user get me and we
have edit user right
so
we go here and
just copy the text here and
write should edit user
it's going to be users
and it's going to be a patch request
and the headers are correct and we need
also a body the body will have the dto
dto edit user dto
and let's just edit the first name
vladimir
and
just the
email
vlad add code with blood dot
and let's push that dto to the body with
body
dto and let's see if we
can get
something interesting so first let's see
this test executes
so
here it goes
should edit user it is executed
interesting and let's maybe inspect that
where's the answer here is this this is
the response so we get the user with the
updated email and with the updated first
name which is quite cool so that works
we can also make our tests a bit more
defined for instance we can say that oh
we expect that the body contains a field
where we expect that the body contains a
first name vladimir and an email of that
well we can just say expect
but it contains
and we can provide a value so it's going
to be dto.firstname
and we can do the same with detail.email
and let's see if our code executes
cool our code is now working obviously
you can test it out you can say expat
body contains
let's say
i don't know
false value
and that should throw an error because
false value is not part of the body
value false value not found in response
body
so that's a handy way of checking if
some fields are there without going too
much into details
okay now let's go ahead and create the
routes for the bookmarks so for the
bookmark we haven't done anything yet we
will need to have a controller and a
service let's go ahead and create those
so nest g controller
bookmark
no spec
and same for the service
very cool we can
clean that out and here what do we need
we need to have a couple of routes okay
bookmarks maybe
put it here as bookmarks we also need to
use some guards so gwt guards you need
to have a access token in order to use
those
routes
so that is
done at all missing imports have we
forgotten something else no i think we
have it all we can close user controller
and just work with bookmarks controller
right now so we have a route to get
all
all the
all the bookmarks so it's going to be
get
get bookmarks
we also have
get bookmark
by id
we have
edit bookmark by id
and maybe delete
bookmark
by id let's check our test if we haven't
forgotten something
create oh create bookmarks as well so we
get bookmarks get bookmark by id
edit bookmark by id and delete bookmark
by id and we also need to have
a route for creation so
create bookmark
that's it we need to have a post
decorator for create bookmark we need to
have a
get decorator for get bookmark byte id
by id let's move it above so gets are in
one place
we also have edit bookmark by id so it's
going to be patch
and delete is going to be delete
so we have a whole crud
crowd thing let's also import the
service because all our business logic
will be in the service
private
book mark
bookmark service
book mark
service
and let's copy all those functions in
in the bookmark service
and just clean the decorators here
here we go
very well now all of them will have to
use get user decorator get user
and it will have to use user id
number
sorry it actually goes
into here
[Music]
and we need to fetch the
id
same goes for here
same goes for here and same goes for
there and the reason why i have to have
the user id is that i can check if a
bookmark belong belongs to a certain
user or not so when we are deleting a
bookmark we need to make sure that we
are not deleting the bookmark of someone
else
and when we get the bookmarks we need to
make sure that we are getting the
bookmark of that user that's why we need
that
so the getbookmark will not need to have
a dto um
this will not need to have a dto either
but it will have to have a param so if
we want to get a
bookmark so get
book marks by id for instance two
or five well this id is called the param
we can get it with another decorator
param
that also comes from nes common and it's
going to
get the id and the name of that variable
will be equal to the variable that we
define here and we need to put two dots
like that and similar to what express
does express also has those
parameters
and it's going to be
book mark id
it's going to be a number
and by default this is going to be a
string but we can convert it to a number
with parse
and pipe
the create bookmark will have to have a
dto so let's go ahead and create that
detail
index
ts and
create
book
mark.tts
export class create book mark dto
and what will the create bookmarked you
have well let's check at our
schema so the bookmark has a title
description which can be
empty and a link okay title description
and link
let's go ahead
and let's add that title
is a string
description
is a string and it can be optional
and
link
is a string as well
and we can use a string
validation
a string
a string
and this can be is optional
and this is is not empty
[Music]
here we go and we can export that
create dto from
the folder
now we can close it all open the
bookmarks and add the dto here as body
[Music]
the dto will map to create
bookmark
dto
and
edit bookmark dto will also have
something similar
and i'm going to show you a cool neat
way to reuse our code and here we have
made an error it should be capital
and it should be capital here because
it's a class
and that should be fixed
above
that's nice and the next thing we said
that we want to have edit bookmark but
id by id okay edit
bookmark
[Music]
dot dto.ts
so what we can do is to just copy what
we have here edit bookmark dto
and
everything could be optional
that's the only difference
here
and
here
this is this is for typescript to know
this is for the validation to know so
you don't get confused
we can change title description and link
and we also need to export that detail
from our
dto folder
and we go back to here and the patch
request will be
edit
bookmark dto
nice and we just need to have the one
last route delete bookmark by id
well it also will
take the
the id here
and we can just reuse the same logic
that we have in
get bookmark by id
here
here we go we have everything that we
need on the controller site now let's
jump into this service site
let's jump into bookmark service so what
do we need to get the bookmark we need
to have user id
which is a number and that's about it
right we don't need to have anything
else yeah just the user id
then we need to get the bookmark by id
well we still need to get the user id
but we also need to have a bookmark id
which will be a number
and create bookmark we need to have the
user id
but we need to have a dto of create
bookmark dto
since it's going to be an object
same for edit
bookmark
dto dot
edit bookmark
dto
and delete bookmark by id is going to be
user id as well
and
bookmark id
like
like here and that's pretty much all our
parameters now we can pass
our
our values here to the service
return
this bookmark service
get bookmarks
user id
we also need to do the same here get
bookmarked by id so
just need to
change it here and you also have the
bookmark id that goes there
and for create bookmark
pretty similar
except that the second argument will be
a dto
and
[Music]
here as well
it's going to be the same dto but it's
going to be
so
create bookmark
edit
bookmark by id
and here we we actually have forgotten
something since it's added a bookmark by
id you say the
id of the bookmark at which you want to
be edited and you provide the body so we
have forgotten also to put a id here
and
let's just copy it here
and provide the bookmark
bookmark id
and then the dto and of course we need
to go
and modify the signature of that
function
and delete the bookmark by id it's going
to be your turn this bookmark service
delete
bookmark byte by id user id and bookmark
id
that's uh that was a bit tedious but we
have all the
logic pretty much programmed from the
from the controller's point of view now
let's go ahead and jump into the service
to
to see how we can make that work
and we're going to do it one by one so
when you write code it's also nice to
actually test it straight away so you
get an immediate feedback
on how your code performs here is going
to be a very wide because we are running
end-to-end tests but usually you would
first go with integration tests but in
our case since the application is quite
simple that's going to do it we rerun
the test
database to make sure that everything is
updated correctly all the files are
generated as they should be we have our
first tests that are being run and let's
go ahead and add the logic for the
second one so the first thing is to
create bookmarks
okay um maybe we can
we can first get the bookmarks get empty
bookmarks first
get empty
bookmarks
so because we wanna kinda
simulate the user experience on our app
if we imagine what the user would be
with end-to-end tests let's actually
close that
close this
to make it a bit more
readable
so we have a sign-up functionality the
user signs up then he signs in
then the user
will get himself and then he can edit
himself so we kind of simulate what the
user can do on the platform then the
user will go on a dashboard or something
and he will get
empty bookmarks because he haven't
created he hasn't created any bookmarks
yet so let's go ahead and simulate that
let's copy this code
and simulate it here
it
should
get bookmarks
return pactum it's going to be bookmarks
it's going to be a get request the
headers can stay the body we don't need
any the status should be
200 and let's inspect
the uh
the result and we see that the body is
actually empty nothing is there and this
is normal because we haven't written any
any logic yet so we can come back to our
bookmark service
and write our logic
so let's import prisma because it's not
imported yet
prisma
prisma service
so get bookmarks we need to return this
prisma
sorry i forgot private
this
this prisma
bookmark
return
[Music]
find many
where
where what where user id
is equal to user id we can just leave it
like that so it's going to return all
bookmarks
that are linked to us to the user that
is doing the request let's see what it
does return and here now we have an
empty array and because by default when
prisma will run find many if it's not
going to find anything it's going to
return an array because you are
expecting to find a lot of elements
right so what we could say
is that
inspect status
expect
body
and here we can say
what the body will expect and it should
be an array an empty array let's see
that works
then we can go ahead and continue with
our logic and we can write the code for
create a bookmark so
same thing return
it should
create
bookmark
[Music]
return packtube spec post
bookmarks
with headers correct and then we need to
provide a dto so let's go ahead and
provide
a dtom here
at that level
create bookmark dto
okay the ty the title should be
it should be
first
bookmark
and the link will be
let's actually put a link to one of the
videos of free code cam i personally
liked the video that guy who teaches
kubernetes really well done man and i'm
going to save this
url in my bookmarks
here we go and we put the dto into
our
with body
it should expect the status of 201
because it's a post request and let's
see what it does
well obviously it will do nothing
because
because we have not programmed the logic
yet so let's go ahead and program the
logic here it is create bookmark so in
the same fashion we can make it
as sync and create our bookmark const
bookmark is equal await
this
prisma
bookmark create
data
and what do we put here first of all the
bookmark is created by a user so we can
say user id is equal user id and then we
can just destructure the detail and then
we can return the bookmark to see what
it does
and let's see if our code executes i'm
going to check here and inspect the the
the
response let's inspect the response
and we see that we have
we have created the first bookmark it is
linked to user id 9
which is the current id and it is the
second bookmark so if we do it again
we see that the id is 3. it's because
while we're cleaning the database we're
not cleaning everything we just clean
the users table and the bookmarks table
there's another table that keeps track
of the indexes and that is not clean and
this is normal that it's going to be
incremented but that's okay it's not a
problem in our case and anyway you
should not in your test relate to
hard-coded ids like here so now we have
created a bookmark and we can go
here into getbookmark and re-execute the
same code
so
let's go ahead here
should get bookmarks and
we can just copy it here
and
let's see that code executes okay cool
we have to get bookmarks and we we had
that and we can inspect that
and we'll probably see that we have an
array
and in that array there is our newly
created bookmark
so now we should have the get bookmarks
and expect the status 200 yes
but now we know that the body should be
an array and it should be one element
inside it so what we can do to make a
very
simple test is that expect
json
length to be one so we can expect the
array of bookmarks should have at least
one element so that's that we can then
proceed and write the logic for getting
the bookmark by id so the way to do it
is to simply should get bookmarked by
id which will copy
the test that we have already so if we
want to get a specific bookmark by id we
can write it like that but we don't know
the id right we were not sure about it
because as i've just said we don't reset
the ids the that has been sequentially
generated by postgres of our elements so
we need to keep track of the bookmark id
that we have created somewhere
so let's go ahead and
where do we create it should create
bookmark this is where we need to use
the stores api like we have used for
user access token so stores
is going to be
book mark id
and it's going to put the id
field of the bookmark inside it
so to use parameters with pactum we need
to use their own kind of way of doing so
we need to tell the id here and with
params with path params
and it's going to be the key is going to
be id
and the value is going to be the value
that we have saved in our in our store
so let's see if that works
very well but now let's write the logic
because we haven't written the logic yet
and we
have the function here get bookmark by
id it's going to be pretty much the same
apart from we are going to use find
first
and we need to get the
bookmark that belongs to a certain id
and which id is also a
a bookmark id provided here and let's go
ahead here let's execute our our logic
and we see that now we have the right
answer
and we can we can go back here
and
do some basic assertions we can say
expect
body contains and it's going to be
what is it going to be the value the
value is going to be
this number which which is which is
going to be the bookmark id
okay let's see if that works
perfect
let's now finish it with edit bookmark
by id and delete bookmark by id before
we go any further let's just examine if
everything is correct get bookmarks
by user id that's fine get bookmark by
id
yes that's okay create bookmark we pass
the user id and the dto that's fine and
edit bookmark by id and this is where we
need to do a bit more work so first of
all we need to get the bookmark
by id
and then we need to check
if user
owns the bookmark
and then only we are going to
do the modifications so the first part
is quite simple
bookmark is equal await this prisma
bookmark
find unique
where
id is called bookmark
id
and then if not bookmark or
so the bookmark at specific id does not
exist or if the user id at the bookmark
is not equal to the user id that means
that if the bookmark that we try to edit
does not own to the current user then we
throw an exception pro
new
forbidden
exception
access to resource
denied
that's
it and the function should be on the
sync function
and we can clean that out we don't need
those parentheses here because we only
have one
throw exception and again it's a guard
condition so it's going to stop the
execution of our code
below so if the bookmark belongs to the
user then only we can modify
the
the user
then only we can modify the bookmarks so
we will return the modified bookmark
this prisma
bookmark
update
where
id is called bookmark id
and the data
will be
dto we're going to just destructure the
ddto here
and we can come back to our test and
just copy
our test here
should edit bookmark by id should
edit bookmark
it's going to be a patch
bookmarks
by id yeah and we
need to take a dto so the dto
is going to be here dto edit bookmark
deal and we're just going to
add the description
and the description was
actually the we're going to
add the title
and
[Music]
and the description
so let's just copy this
[Music]
and we pass that dto to the body weighs
body
here we expect the status of 200
and let's
first execute it and inspect that
to make sure that we have the right
things
awesome we have the right things and we
can just
expect the title and description to the
to be of those values
let's um i see that we have a white
space here
let's
expect body contains
dto dot
title
and same for dto the description
let's see our test
awesome that works
and now let's run our last test so
usually when you delete a resource the
status that is returned is a 204
let's see if we can we can actually do
that so
first of all should should delete
delete book
delete bookmark
so it's going to be delete
with path param id yes with headers
correct we don't need any body we don't
and let's see if that works
okay one thing that i like to use when i
delete resources i like to have the code
204
so
we're going to modify it a bit http
coden like we have seen before http
status
null content
which is which stands for code 204
and if we go back to the test and run
them again we now have an error we can
of course go ahead and just modify that
and we can return back to our bookmark
service and fill the last
logic here
and we don't want to return anything so
it's going to be a sync function well
here we also need to
check if the user
owns the bookmark so we can just copy
copy it here
and if the user owns the bookmark then
we can go ahead and delete it
so await
um this prisma
bookmark delete
where
id is equal bookmark id
and that's pretty much it that will
delete our bookmark
let's come back here and just after the
delete let's make another
api request
should get
empty bookmarks
and what we can do is that we can just
copy
the
should get bookmarks here
and
and expect the json length to be
to be of zero
let's come back and run our tests
and yeah amazing
we now have a
end-to-end tested
crowd api
with authentication so i hope that you
enjoyed this tutorial that you have
learned something out of it of course
there's a lot of stuff that
we can still do we can
work on security when we deploy our api
we can run it in a cluster mode through
pm2 and we can do a lot of amazing
things with that library called nesgs
furthermore to improve the code coverage
of this app we can add integration
testing and unit testing but so far my
mission here is accomplished i have
taught you how to use nesh yes and how
to make a solid use of its architecture
my name is vladimir i hope you like this
tutorial
and see you for more at code with vlad